Is that the noise?
The noise.
Jamie's got a much more
subtle than Brian's fucking
monkey noises. Hey everybody.
What the fuck's going on?
How are you living? Huh?
This episode of the podcast is
brought to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is been responsible for at
least three meals that I have every week
now.
And uh,
other folks in my house he did to blue
apron is this new deal and this is what
they do.
They send you all the ingredients in
the exact portions for excellent meals
along with detailed instructions,
recipe instructions with photographs.
So it's like totally
idiot proof. Um, I've,
I've cooked a bunch of
different stuff now. Um,
I've made these awesome chicken
skewers the other day and these,
I'm stuffed peppers and they
were like a spicy pepper too.
It's like this bell pepper,
but it was kind of spicy but really good,
like interesting Mexican
ingredients in it. So what I'm,
what I'm getting at is they're not,
it's not bland food. It's healthy. The,
they range between 500 and
700 calories per serving.
But you would not guess that you would
think that it'd probably be more than
that.
They're really well designed and
they're done by excellent chefs and uh,
you know,
really nutritionally sound too
very healthy and shipping is free.
And I, I'm a big fan of this.
I really love it. Short Rib
Burgers on Pretzel Buns.
Kung Pao chicken tacos.
You can try it out.
Your first two meals for free by going
to blue apron.com/rogan that's blue
apron.com/rogan for your
first two meals for free.
Like I'm gonna give you some examples.
Um, Mexican style Turkey burgers,
cod with pickled grapes and summer
succotash shaking beef with jasmine lime
rice. I don't know what shaking beef
is, but I bet it's fucking delicious.
Chicken with candied
pistachios in snow pea radish.
Sautee really good stuff.
Like interesting stuff.
Indian style salmon with Tomato
Chutney and cranberry bean stew.
Almost like something. Steve
Rinella. Mike Cook on meat eater.
Ladies and gentlemen. It's great stuff.
And like I said, first two meals for free,
give it a shot. Blue apron.com/rogan
I stand by them. I use it every week.
I actually got, uh, they gave me a
phone call today, uh, that I, uh,
got one that's a at my
box today. So, um, uh,
I will be eating some blue apron tonight.
So give it a shot,
blue apron.com and um,
use the code word Blue Apron dog,
blue apron.com/rogan.
That's what you have to do to get
your first two meals for free.
So that's blue apron.com/rogan and enjoy.
We're also brought to you by me undies,
me undies. Now I'm a guy that he usually,
I usually get an underwear
but just buy underwear.
Like I would buy them online in like bulk.
I'd buy like 24 packs on your were from
like amazon.com or something like that.
And they're always cheap underwear.
But um,
me and he started sending me these
underwear that they make a couple of weeks
ago and they're way better.
They just feel better.
They're like looser and more comfortable.
I don't like shopping.
I don't like to go places and spend,
I don't have any fucking time, man.
I don't have the time to go and
pick out underwear. So I would,
if I was shopping and I was
passing the underwear thing,
I would just reach and grab
one and throw it in there.
I wouldn't think at all about it.
But with me undies you can get really
good underwear delivered to you.
Now this is where it's fucked up.
A recent survey showed that men kept her
underwear for an average of seven years
thinking,
I mean I dunno about you,
but when I'm alone I do not
hold back on any farts. Okay?
I'm not scared of my own farts.
I cut them loose.
So seven years of filter and farts.
I just do not trust any washing machine
to to like really do a good job enough
to, I comfortably set my balls after
seven years and that kind of a filter.
So get rid of your fucking underwear
and get some real underwear.
That's my point.
Go to me undies.com they have excellent
underwear that feels great and they even
pull moisture away from your body,
so keeps your balls nice
and smooth and cool.
Me undies has the most comfortable
underwear you have ever tried.
They fit perfectly. They don't
ride up on you. And again,
they literally pull moisture away from
your skin. So you're cool all day long.
Now that I've worn these underwear,
I just got a new box.
Then they just send them straight to a,
now that I've warned them,
I'll never go back. Me undies,
my favorite underwear for sure.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Rogan before September 1st
you can get 20% off your first order.
That's me,
undies.com forward slash Rogan
for 20% off your first order.
If you go there before September 1st uh,
a guarantee,
you're going to be happy with them, they
guarantee you're going to be happy with,
I would trust me once you feel me undies
feel the difference between a real good
pair of underwear.
Just invest.
Invest in the covers of your
balls and your Dick Declaration.
The gentleman. That ad works so good.
I'm on their website right now. Are you?
You're like, yes. That phone
is pretty done. Haven't done.
I haven't really made this happen.
I've been neglecting,
not that it'll buy new underwear,
but I haven't had a
technological jump and underwear
for so long.
Yeah, I haven't either. You know,
one of the things I learned from you
from hanging out with you is the power of
wool and, um, I've been
trying to frame, yeah,
you're trying to find good wool
socks. Like athletic socks. Yeah.
Do they have them?
They do the Rehab Merino blend.
You may get like a thinner Merino blend.
They have like athletic socks, like, I
don't know. I don't know if it's that,
I don't know if they qualify him as
athletic. I like, I've never seen one.
It's meant for like going to the gym.
They're always kind of meant for like,
they'll call them light hiking.
Oh No.
That's why I need some light wool because
it seems like that's what you should
have. Right. So, I mean, that's all I
wear now. It's the best first fruit.
I'm still stuck in the ice age or the,
what do you call it, with stone ages?
Underwear. Anondi's man. But first light,
they make a Merino wool boxer. Oh, that
people love. Yeah, I would imagine.
First light's great. Um, that's
l, I t e is it l? I t. T. Yeah.
light.com marina wool boxer.
But for reasons I don't, I, I,
I could tell you about them.
I need to,
I need something that's nice and I wear
a nice tight fit and pair of underwear.
He too. Yeah. I don't want my ball was
hot and humid. That's what I'm saying.
And uh, last but not least,
we're brought to you by tig. Uh,
if you go to rogan.ting.com you can
understand what ting is all about.
Ting is a cell phone company that uses
a sprint backbone and they cell phones.
You don't, you know, like Lisa phone
from them. So if you cancel, you're done.
If you decide to, uh, you know, you
no longer want to, we'll use ting.
You own that phone, that's yours. Um,
and they have no termination fees,
no contracts, all the bullshit that's
usually connected to cell phones.
They don't have any of that.
With Ting with ting does is they decided
to rent time on the sprint backbone.
So you using sprint service.
But they do it their way and their way
is definitely going to save you money.
98% of people would save money with Ting.
I use Ting Ting is the official
cell phone of this podcast.
I just got my newest one recently
and it is, uh, I fucking love it.
It's the Samsung Galaxy s four.
It's a little smaller than the one
you got this one right here? Yep.
What do you have to note? Yeah, my and my
new me undies looked good on there, man.
The note is pretty dope. But
what I like about this, it
has a Builtin, um, built in,
um, a heart monitor right
there. It's a pulse detector.
Finds out what your heart rate is like.
Don't just put your finger on it,
put your finger on there and it has
apps that go along with it and it's also
waterproof.
That's one of the reasons why I got or
water resistant and should say they don't
see this little tab.
There's tabs shuts down and boom.
And that's just sent to me by tank.
This is the official cell phone of
the Joe Rogan experience podcast. Um,
what they do is they charge,
this is one of the reasons why you saved
money is a lot of companies like if you,
um, if you've got a plan like
get a hundred minutes a month,
if you use 80 of those minutes, you don't
get any credit for those 20 minutes.
If you use 120 minutes, they charge
you extra. You get like an overage fee.
Tang has none of that.
You only use what you pay for.
And 98% of people would save money
with Ting. That's a real figure.
I have had no one who's used ting that
has not told me it's a way better service
as far as like saving money.
And again, you're using sprint,
so it's not like some rinky dink cell
phone service where you're not going to
get good coverage.
$21 is the average monthly bill
per device for 10 customers.
And they have, if you go to the shop, uh,
at a rogan.ting.com there are all sorts
of different cell phones to choose from,
from the really cheap,
you can get like a wonky ass little tiny
smart phone like to HTC evo four g 49
bucks. You can even get a flip phone.
They still sell flip phones, Samsung, uh,
m 472 bucks,
little flip phone.
Or you can get us an apple iPhone
and they have the full range.
You can get like an iPhone four
if you're not, if you're like,
I want an iPhone but I don't need the
latest shit, just give me something cheap.
You get that for 95 bucks.
Or you can go all the way up and get
like the latest and greatest like the
Samsung Galaxy s four or s five,
the sound,
the galaxy note, which
is, um, the note three,
they have that for sale as well.
They have all the latest and
greatest android devices.
So go to rogan.ting.com and you'll
save 25 bucks off of those. All right,
we're done with commercials. Steven
now is here, ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to get down to business.
We're going to talk, not even business.
Well like bullshit
experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Brian Cowen was going to try to make
it here today. Oh really? But he um,
he had some podcasts.
He's scheduling advance.
I tried to get him to cancel
but he couldn't lease your bed.
But he's very excited to come in those
till Laska and that should be a nice
silly trip
man. I'm, I'm looking, I'm excited
about that trip. It really is.
When you get up into that,
when I say that when you
get up into the Alpine zone,
like the above timberline in southeast
Alaska, it really like, you know,
it's cooler looking than like
the walk forest, you know?
I mean it's just as amazing because you
have this like you go from old growth
stuff where you could, like the
three of us could all stand around,
joined hand to hand and you couldn't
reach around these trees, you know? Wow.
And you climb a little
higher and it's like boom.
It's just like wide open and there's,
there's really nothing like it.
I mean, you can't, you just can't
fathom the beauty of it, you know? Well,
I've seen it on your show
where you went hunting blacktail deer,
right when you land on a float plane and
then you go up into the, uh, into the,
the upper regions.
That was where the fog rolled in.
And you had that nice deer in your scope.
No wait. You know, that that time when
I was up there, there was a wind storm.
The wind was so bad, it made the front
page news and town and I'm 70. They, they,
they kept saying like 70 some mile an
hour winds blew down a bunch of phone
poles the next day, uh, uh,
a pilot came up to kind of fly over to
see if we were still alive and everything.
You know, he just kind of
cruise around a check. It was,
that's the thing is the weather.
So when we go on this trip,
we could either just get,
we can either have the worst time or
the best time depending, you know,
I mean just depending on the weather,
it can be so just uncomfortable and
miserable or it can be just beautiful.
And there's places back in there. You
know, principals island is huge. It's the,
I think by some definitions,
either the second or
third or fourth biggest island we have.
What's interesting about it that island
is, it has, you know, half the, sir,
I think it's half the surface area
as Hawaii, the big island in Hawaii,
but has like three times the
coastline. Whoa. Just, you know,
it's just a crazy like
fjords and inlets and bays.
But there are places in
this island that you,
you can't really, there's no road
system in la, in La and a lot of it,
and there's places you can't fly to
because there's no lakes to land and it's
really hard to walk there.
So sometimes you're looking at,
there's mountains there and you're
like, I guarantee that no one, you know,
you can't guarantee it. But I mean
like for a hundred years it's probably,
no one has stepped foot on that
thing because you really had,
we'd have to get to one place and you'd
have to get a boat and carry it through
and go across to another
place and then climb up. Well,
it'd be mostly just climate.
Like you just, when you,
if you fly over some of those mountain
tops and you look around, there's,
this is no way. I just know that no one's
been there unless you could land up,
lets you can land up there on a lake,
you know,
we'll land not will land in a spot.
And I want to just walk from there and
I think we will walk up into stuff that,
that people haven't walked there.
I mean,
there's always some crazy
thing he didn't know about,
but we're going to walk into some stuff
where people just have not walked. Well,
you know,
you can stand around places there and say,
I like,
you know,
I feel very certain that I'm
like definitely the first
guy to ever have his feet
sitting right here. I can't discount
something that happened, you know,
hundreds and hundreds of years ago.
But there's just some wild stuff in there.
Wow. It's, it's uh, you know, right
now I've got mixed feelings about too,
but they just, the forest service up there
just announced they're going to be, uh,
open up cut up there.
6,000 acres of old growth for clear cuts.
Yeah. Wow. That's kind of fucked
up dude. I understand every single,
I understand every single
argument for and against.
I understand every single argument.
What's for, what's the good aspect of it?
The economics.
I mean,
that's like you used to have a thriving
logging industry based around Tongass,
you know, Tongass national forest.
So it just atrophied. Right?
So it's a job creation
thing, you know? I mean that,
that's the for the forage is just people
that live there have an access to like
a good paying job.
The downside is we have just a
minuscule fraction of old growth left,
you know? Yeah. Just, I don't see
why anybody would allow that. I mean,
I understand the economic thing,
but I always feel like there's
gotta be another way to make money.
What's weird too is Tom has just said
recently that over the next decade they're
looking to phase out old growth
logging at the same time that they are
announcing and pushing forward with plans
to do a big 6,000 acre clear cut sort
of sort of acknowledging on one hand they
they want to get out of it or need to
get out of it or can see into the
future that need to get out of it.
And An air hammer being like,
but we'll have one last Hoo Rah,
I got one last party.
And you're dealing with,
how old do you think these trees are?
I mean these, you know, there's the,
I can't speak specifically
to that particular area,
but I mean there's like Doug
firs that are much older than,
than the birth of this nation
out and cedars. I mean, you know,
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
years old. That's huge. Giant trees.
Chop them down and make what?
It's sad man. But you know paper,
like everything gets so weirdly, we've
talked about this before on the show,
how things get so convoluted, like one
of the big, just to bring it back to us,
going on a hunt for CYCA black tail deer,
like they'll sick a black tail deer
when we're going to look for him,
we're going to be looking for him up in
the Alpine, which they'll be leaving.
So there'll be leaving around
the time we're going there.
That stuff's still has snow.
Like we're,
we're going to be looking for deer
will still have snow in June. Okay.
Then it melts off and there's long days
and it turns like beautiful and it gets
very vibrant and green.
There's all kinds of succulents and
deer come up out of the timber to feed
around in there and then
in October it snows.
So you have like a couple snow free
months in October it snows and those deer
all split.
Traditionally what those deer want to
do is they want to go down and spend the
winter down in old growth because the
old growth canopy allows for a kind of a,
you know, a snow free sheltered
understory where they're, you know,
down on the down in the ground and they'll
hang out in that old growth timber.
So an argument against the cut
would be that we need it for deer.
And a further argument would be the
reason we need to protect deer habitat is
because we needed to protect
the wolves out there.
And some people right now are trying to
make a push to say that the wolves in
the Alexander Archipelago of which Prince
of Wales island is a part that those
wolves are genetically extinct and they
therefore deserve a level of protection,
like their own level of protection that
they would get endangered species act
protection out on these islands
when other people are arguing.
It's just the same wolf man.
I mean it's like you got wolves all over.
It doesn't like that population
doesn't deserve any specific thing.
So it winds up being that people who
might be pushing against the timber sale
might wind up also be angling
for protecting wolves out
there from hunting and
trapping. And then you're
left to be like, well,
I'm not really comfortable
with the timber sale,
but I'm not really comfortable with you
using biological lumping and splitting
in order to like close down
certain sorts of hunting season.
So it winds up being that all your
friends aren't necessarily, you know,
like the enemies of your enemies
aren't necessarily your friends. Wow,
wow. Wow. So anyways, we're
going into that area and
hunt some black tail deer and there's
a health is a good healthy population.
You know, it's still good. Even a non
resident, you're allowed two bucks.
And do they um, do they have
bear up there? Is it black pair?
You have to think about the bears.
You'll see some bear droppings or
bear scat or bear shit here and there.
But those bears out there,
so tuned in on the salmon runs that
they really don't spend a lot of time.
Um,
I think some move,
but they really don't spend a lot of time
feeding in those areas because they're
down 2000 feet. Timberline
is like 1800, 2000 feet.
They're down 2000 feet lower in
the river, miles feed, non salmon.
And we, and we'd like to have, you know,
that image of the bear grabbing a salmon
out and he's all silver and shiny and
healthy and floppy, but long after the
runs are kind of done, they're down.
They're just, they're down. They're just
feeding and rotten fish laying around.
I've watched,
I've watched wolves,
they're eating dead saying I watch five
wools one time eating dead salmon that
were the consistency of pudding.
Whoa. Just mopping it up.
They must have unbelievable stomach
fat, man. You can't even imagine. So,
um, there's not a lot of bears up
there. You know, there's a lot of,
you see some barriers around,
but I think that so many of the
bears are focused on that stuff.
One thing you find some people say,
and in those islands in southeast Alaska,
dude,
they're like,
they tend to be either a black bear
island or a grizzly island and it just,
and it changes. So you'd be on one island
and it's black bears, another island,
islands,
grizzlies.
And it's sort of this weird phenomenon
that they don't readily mix.
You get an interior areas on the mainland
where you have grizzlies and black
bears coexist.
Oftentimes the grizzlies will dominate
the salmon streams and you'll have more
black bears up high.
So you could be standing on a mountain
a couple thousand feet above sea level,
and it's just black bears everywhere on
top of the mountain feed on blueberries.
And you're looking down
at Primo salmon streams,
but just big brown bears being grizzlies
down there and they kind of hoard the
spot and the blackberries
don't get in there. They just
can't. They, they, you know,
they're kind of enemies. Yeah, they'll eat
them too. Right. They'll eat grizzlies.
Yeah. The, uh, the place that I was
up in Alberta, we went bear hunting.
They take a carcasses after they
cut the back straps off in the Hams,
they'll take like the
body cavity and they,
they leave it in certain areas where
they know grizzlies are to keep the
grizzlies coming over there. Right? Yeah.
Cause they don't want the grizzlies
coming to the, um, the other, uh, Bates,
the baits they have out for the
black pair of no one can do,
they have to abandon that bill
because it's just too sketchy.
They have some photos from
track camera trap photos,
these fucking enormous grizzlies wandering
standing up on black bears. Yeah.
I got a buddy who saw one time,
he witnessed a grizzly kill,
a black bear disemboweled it and eat
its liver. Whoa. Yeah. And there's a,
there's a very well regarded
hunting guide in Alaska,
is written some good hunting books
about Alaska named Tony Ross.
And I was reading his book on
Hunting Kodiak or he's got,
he's got a book on Hunting Brown bears
and grizzlies in Alaska and live his
experiences around Kodiak
and the Alaska peninsula.
And he was saying he's never seen.
And just the backup for
a minute on Kodiak a sig,
like if you map out a bear's diet,
okay.
A bear bore bear male,
Brown bear Grizzly,
you know brown bear on Kodiak.
If you met Bob as annual die,
what he's tuned into in the
spring are brown bear cubs.
Yeah, he's like males, right?
He's like wakes up and he's hunting
brown bear cubs and as a sick fuck
significant part of his diet.
But what Tony Ross has said and
all of his years of guiding,
he's never seen where when you
kill a big mature Bor brown bear,
he's never seen where another brown bear
will come and scavenge that carcass.
Wow. They'll skate. They even with the
things skinned out and butchered. Right.
They recognize through smell or whatever.
They will not mess with that thing.
That's what he says. Black
and his guys seen. Oh yeah.
And this guy has seen a lot,
but he was saying nothing will touch
those big boars. The body on him too.
Scared of. I just, I don't
know, even with some the bottom,
the smell or something and they just
know that they don't want anything to do
with it.
Wow.
When we were in a Alberta,
one of the guys shot a bear late at
night and they didn't want to retrieve it
because there was too many bears in
the area. It was just getting sketchy.
They shot the bear like right at the
moment where it's getting dark out and the
bear ran off and they just said,
we'll come back in the morning.
So they came back in the morning and a
big bore was eating the other black bear.
Oh really? So they had, they were
taking selfies like smiling while there,
there was a bear behind them eating a bear
carcass.
They have new buddy of where he got one
and trail he shot one was Bo and track
that the morning and had it was just gone,
had been consumed.
So crazy. Yeah. Yeah. That's, that's
the wild man. When we were up there,
one of the bears, one of the Boers
had a attacked, a sow killed.
It's cub and left half the cubs body and
then the south came back and finished
it off. She ate her own basically. Yeah.
She ate her own baby in front of them
while they were in the, in the stand.
I've heard competing theories about that,
that on one hand the board just is
doing it because he wants to eat,
but there seems to be this upside where
there's an additional upside besides
chloric intake.
Did a boar will kill a south cubs
and she'll come back into estrus?
Yeah, so when a sound like a,
a sound's to, she'll have her,
her cubs in the den in February and
March. Okay. There's little hairless.
It's Joanie,
you know,
she had them prior to seize the hairless
little things and she'll take care of
them. She'll emerge from her
dad, but he's a little fur balls.
She'll stay with them all summer long.
She'll den with them again.
She'll come out again and usually at some
point that summer she might get rid of
him and so she's going to be off like
she won't cycle again potentially for two
years. So if a bar has in
his area, he hangs out,
he's got a half dozen females.
Apparently it's worth the risk to him
that he might be, I'm talking in a,
in a genetic sense,
it's worth the risk to him that he
might be killing his own offspring,
which probably has no
idea whether it is or not,
kill his own offstring
offspring in order to,
to have that female go back into
estrus and then breed her. Wow. Nature,
whatever kind of calculation.
He's probably not, I mean,
obviously he's not making
that calculation. He's
probably just going like,
I'm hungry, but an added benefit
of it is apparently he get,
he might double back around and you know,
and get her again and make love to
the woman who's children he consumed.
Well,
dolphins actually have a strategy against
that because one of the things that a
lot of people are not aware we think of
dolphins is being really sweet and kind
and they're nice to people. But
dolphins, they eat their own babies. No,
I didn't know that. Well, they don't eat
their own babies, but they dolphin babies.
And what a male dolphin finds a female
that he has never had sex with and she
has babies.
They'll oftentimes kill the babies and
they'll kill the babies to force a woman
to back to breeding again because
she'll go on a seven year cycle.
So when a female dolphin has a baby,
she will not breed again for seven years.
While that baby is being raised and and
growing legs, they put a huge investment.
The strategy for female dolphins is
they are sluts and they fuck as many
dolphins as they can so that when the
mail comes around and he sees her with the
babies, like that might be
my fucking kid. All right,
I'm not going to kill that kid because
that's what keeps them from killing the,
the, the feed those babies. It's really
why, because they're thinking, I mean,
they're really intelligent animals.
They have a cerebral cortex.
It's 40% larger than a human beings.
And in a matter of fact,
anybody who's listening to this checkout
radio lab radio lab has an amazing
podcast. The one that's on
this week, it's called hello,
and it's all about John Lilly.
And John Lily's work with
interspecies communication with,
you know who John Lilly was? He was
a no, no, I don't know that name.
Maniac crazy man.
And uh,
these other scientists that worked
with him actually wound up taking his
research and bringing it to some
new place because Lilly, uh,
he was also the inventor
of the isolation tank.
He created a sensory deprivation tank
because he was, he was a pioneer.
You're a fan of huge fan Lilly.
Uh,
we would take acid and set up a tank next
to the dolphins and he would take acid
going into the isolation tank and
try to communicate with the dolphins.
So while the dolphins were like
make all these weird noises,
he would like try to decipher those
while he was on acid in his tank.
And he eventually went off the deep end
with like really getting like heavily,
heavily into ketamine and all these
weird tranquilizers and drugs and became
actually addicted to ketamine.
And that's when he lost all his funding.
Nobody wanted to have anything to do
with it when it came to this dolphin
research anymore cause they
knew that he was doing that.
And one of the women that he had
hired to um, live with a dolphin,
they had like an apartment set
up. Oh, where it was underwater.
It was essentially to her it
was like waist high and water.
And she had a dolphin that she lived
with for like six months in this and she
wound up like jerking the dolphin off
because the dolphin would like humper leg
all the time. It'd be really distracting.
Cause was a young dolphin. So she's like,
let me just take care of that for you.
And she would just jerk this dolphin off
and then you know, to her it was like,
look, he's got an issue and
it's getting in the way of work,
so I'll just take care of
that. But everybody else was
like, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
You're doing scientific research
by jerking off dolphins. Like yeah,
I could see that. Yeah. She might
need a cop minutes to explain herself.
But the,
the podcasts or sort of focuses on
dolphin communication and they're there,
the difficulty that they have.
Like they know that the dolphins
want to communicate with them,
but they have that blow hole and
that's how they make their noise.
So it's really hard for them to make
noises that mimic human noises cause they
don't really have the ability to
make ms and teas and all these dishes
completely different.
So in the,
in the podcasts you hear her talking to
the Dolphin and the dolphin trying to
imitate what she saying. It's
crazy. Right? It's amazing.
You get into it. Like when you
get into animal communication,
so much of it becomes
semantical or an argument of
semantics where he'd say like, we're,
we're the only thing with
language. And people be like,
well, you know, actually x,
Y and Z has something.
Okay,
well I mean we're the only thing with
complex language, any big, well, you know,
some animals are actually able to convey,
you know,
fairly complex things like
that. There's, you know, a,
a Predator above us and like,
well what I mean is they don't
have syntax. Right. You know,
and you kind of like wine up right now.
It's like the verdict's still out man.
There's some like animals do convey some
complicated stuff and bace brothers or
cologists you know like phd scientists
and they kind of hate the conversation,
you know, because they really
resist, not resistant to,
but they have a hard time with trying
to use our terminology and use our
language to describe what animals are
up to. Right. You know, like to say for,
for you to say that the dolphin eats
the bay or doesn't want to eat the baby
because it might be his baby.
Someone might argue that that animal
probably has no comprehension of that or
even that they are not able to
equate sex with reproduction.
Hmm.
They're so intelligent though. I don't
know how they wouldn't be able to equate.
I don't,
I don't either.
I don't think this all the time because
I really should have said killed.
They killed him. I don't, I
don't think they eat them.
They might say they really ran,
but they killed him. They bite him.
You know, I struggled this
stuff all the time because,
you know, as a hunter I'm always
weighing out like, well what is it like,
what are the things that we're after and
what are their capabilities? You know,
I don't want to fall into
some trap or I just act like,
oh that just like corn with
legs, you know. So I do,
I am curious all the time about the
capabilities of animals and I tend to be
open to the idea that there's,
there's like different sets of experiences
that different animals have. You know,
there's some have more, perhaps more
of an awareness than others. Yeah.
You know, there's like a,
there's a hierarchy if you will.
And I think that the consensus is
that dolphins are pretty high on that
hierarchy.
Yeah. Dolphins and Orcas, of course,
orchids are very high up on that. They,
and they eat dolphins.
That's what's really fucked up.
You know, I've been going through
some of my kid, man. He um,
we just moved to the Pacific northwest
and so I keep talking to them.
I kid about, everything's got a killer
whale on it, you know, like, like stores,
grocery stores, whatever. It just
like a common motif. And I'm like,
I would tell him that's a killer whale.
It's a killer whale.
And I know the lot of people like
to call them or it goes, you know,
in is some Greek word I think just
means Sateesh and just means whale.
It's a pretty generic term.
And some people say that killer whale
killer whales used to be called whale
killers and whale killer became killer
whale. So I'm always telling my kid,
all that's killer whale.
And one day my kid comes home and he
just madder than hell because he learned
that it's not a killer whale. It's ORC.
You know? And I'm like, listen man,
I know what I like.
I know what the person who told
you that is trying to tell you.
And I already know that,
but I told you killer whale,
not because I wasn't aware because I
was trying to circumvent, you know,
I was trying to do,
to come back around against what you
would inevitably learn about it's PC name.
Uh, I say, you know, you
were planning in advance.
It wasn't that I didn't know.
I was just trying to fill you up with,
just to open you to the idea that,
that there's the animals get new
names all the time and it's just a PC.
It's like a, it's like a, um, what do
you call it? Like a marketing term? Yeah.
Cause as a marketing term
scholar mean it's not a whale.
It's a tooth whale is it? But
a dolphins. A tooth. We'll too,
because I thought,
pardon me?
I thought you were saying that someone
wasn't a mammal or something. Oh No, it's,
it's a, it's a cousin of a dolphin.
Right? You know, I don't know,
like taxonomically where's it
at? I'd be, I'd be curious.
I'm pretty sure it's a no.
Yeah, because I'm pretty sure there's
a word crazy video of one keel.
They're killing a whale while it's alive.
These killer whales are behind.
That's how most killing happens.
Yeah. But I mean, it's, it's,
I should say they're eating
it while it's alive. Oh.
Fighting chunks of its face off.
And it's just so hard to watch because
we think of these whales as being these
beautiful creatures.
And we think of why we have this weird
idea of killer whales as being like these
really noble creatures.
You know?
Cause I always think of killer whales
as being like the friend of man.
And that's why when one
does freak out at seaworld,
it makes seaworld looks so horrible
because in the wild there's almost no
evidence whatsoever that whales have
ever killed anybody. But he's probably,
after awhile I was like, what
am I supposed to kill them?
Yeah, yeah. Exact killer.
Exactly. Whale. And the instincts that
they have, you know, I was, the way,
I always equated,
one of the things I have a problem with
zoos in general is that they don't allow
animals to do their natural thing.
I really think that would zoos should be,
is get all motherfuckers together.
You should have a giant piece of
land of you gonna fence it in,
let them in there and let them run wild.
And if people really want to see animals,
what they should see is Jaguars
killing monkeys. And the whole goal,
the whole gamut and it sounds fucked up.
But that's really what the wild is.
Cause what we're doing by taking these
animals and putting them in these weird
cages is we're creating these closed
in ecosystems where these animals never
have to compete there. Food is given to
them and we're ruining their genetics.
I mean those animals that are in zoos,
they're completely incapable of ever being
reintroduced into the wild unless you
take them.
And it would have to be some
really exhausting effort
to try to reintroduce them
to the idea of hunting their own food
or cat a gathering their own food.
But those fucking dummies
that you have in the zoo,
you've created these welfare monkeys,
these monkeys that just,
I shouldn't say welfare should say
like their pets. They're like dogs.
It's like expecting your dog to figure
out how to go hunting when he's just
sitting there wagging his tail,
waiting for you to open up a can of alto.
They don't know any better,
but what zoos using their defense and
you know some people we've kind of gotten
away from, a lot of people have
gotten away from aesthetically,
so like the bear in the
cage kind of display,
but what zoos are eyes able to use in
their defense is that with cases like the
panda, Florida Panther, oh did
they have a genetic reserve? Right.
So maybe they're not,
maybe they're not insuring behavior.
They're not like protecting behavior,
but they're at least protecting
like the genetic reserve. Yeah.
Shit hit the fan for some species
you have that. And there's many,
many examples of things that you know
of wild populations that had been
supplemented through the zoo stuff.
But I know what you're saying.
Like I don't like I,
when I take my kid to a zoo,
I remember we were sitting
there looking at this like,
I mean just the pathetic example of a,
of a grizzly bear.
I remember just kind of wanting to look
at my son and be like, listen dude,
you're getting the wrong idea. These
things are bad ass normally, you know,
it's just kind of sad.
Have you seen that show,
the hunt that I told you about?
No. No, I didn't see it, but I remember
you talking about it pretty interesting.
I don't think I write about it after you
showed it after you told me about it,
because the guy from Metallica was
narrating it and then he got, he,
their band got punished
and weren't allowed to
play at a music festival. They were
trying to ban them. I don't take it.
What the fuck is this? Because he
narrated a show. James Hetfield. Yeah,
he's a good narrator. It's interesting.
And he's a hunter. He hunts a lot and uh,
there's a photo of him with his
fucking giant pair. Holy Shit. I mean,
it's a perspective shot, you know,
they always put the bear. Yeah,
we getting way back. But, but
this fucking bear is huge. I mean,
it's like a nine foot bear.
It's enormous.
Is it just the shoulders on this fucking
thing and the head on this thing,
it's just this and he's standing in front
of people like, Oh my God, disgusting.
Evil. But they don't understand
is if you truly love bears,
you got to kill that bear
because if you don't kill
that bear that bear,
those big giant bears are responsible
for decimating the population of cubs.
That's what they do.
And if you don't trim the big ones,
if you don't kill some of the big ones,
there's a photo of him with the bear.
I mean data is a fucking big, where
was that? Was that Cody? Kodiak?
Kodiak, yeah. He shot went up there
while he was doing that show. Apparently.
I mean they are enormous and you might
see like someone might see that you
killed a big male bear and,
and be upset by it,
but you're really not
impacting the bear population.
You know,
you're impacting that individual bear
but you're not having any kind of real
longterm deleterious effect on the bears
of the island, which are very, you know,
it's a very stable, well-regulated
population of bears out there.
I put it in for that tag.
I think as a non guided nonresident.
So like if you're wanting to go with the
guide, you can go to Kodiak and haunt,
you know,
you just go book a trip and go.
So you just have to pay them and they
have a certain amount of tax. They it's,
I don't know what it is,
you might pay 25 30 grand for the hunt.
It's interesting watching it but non
guided non resident that's always put in
for it. There's a very limited number
of tags for non guided nonresident,
which mean that I would have
to go in lieu of a guide.
I get her like, because my
brother is a resident of Alaska,
I don't need to use a guide when hunting
animals that you normally need the
guide to hunt.
So I can go with him and hunt there.
And so every other year they do a thing
where you can apply for the spring hunt.
I always put in for that hunt and then
when you're talking about that show,
I was bummed because I was like,
now the odds of drawing that
tag are probably gonna for
a long time. Go Way, way,
way down because it's probably gonna be
a ton of dudes putting in for the permit
now. Yeah, it could be wrong.
Probably like it's going to increase
interest and now I'm like trying to think
of a new place to start putting in. I've
never killed a grizzly bear. I want to,
I really wanted to one time.
Well,
you also have a weird thing where you
want a grizzly bear to scratch your chest
and leave scars.
Why would you say it meant a lot
more than me when I was single?
That just seems like one of
the worst requests. However,
like a fucking giant bay. I mean, what
did, what is a full grown grizzly way?
What's the way? I mean, there's a magical
number that gets thrown around a lot.
It's like when people were on, when
people want to say that a bear was huge,
they say it was a thousand pounds.
Right?
But those I guess are like,
if you put a lot of thousand pound bears
on a scale there, 800 pounds. Okay,
there's 750 pounds, a hundred
pounds. You know, again at Tony,
Russ got it that wrote those
books I was talking about has a,
he's at an immense amount of experience
and he kind of has a passage in there
where he talks about like the thousand
pound bear and there just aren't a lot of
them out there is as much as you read
people getting like 10 foot thousand pound
bears, you, you,
you and I laughed about this before
because everyone that sees a mountain lion
in the wild
always says, um, big fucking
bore, you know, 200 pound boar.
And I remember like,
I laugh because you saw a lion and you
said it look like a small one. I was like,
you're the first guy I've ever met
the sauce, small y. I see two of them.
They were both around the same weight.
The first one I saw was like a dog size.
It's like 60, 70 pounds. And the second
one, it was a much quicker view of them.
But again, I thought it was a
coyote until I saw its tail.
And then I noticed it had this big
bouncy tale. It was in Santa Barbara.
I was in Monosito driving through a
residential neighborhood and were like,
my wife said it was so afraid.
She goes, coyote and I go,
Oh Shit, look at its tail.
And we're like, that's a
mountain lion. It was like,
so it was like in that time
we saw it in the headlights,
couldn't have been more than 70 pounds.
You're discerning individual did
not have seen a 200 pound towns,
so there's the thousand pound bear,
but that that bear,
we're just looking at it as it is a huge
variable. I don't know what he, well,
did you see that video that's been
going around lately of a bear that was
walking around on two legs and
people were saying, is this big foot?
Is this what people are seeing?
Because it's absolutely a black bear
and this bear just for whatever reason
that's a size to get around. He walked
like a long distance on two legs.
It gets a crazy video.
Pull that video up Jamie,
because it's the one in the
neighborhood, right? Yeah. Yeah.
It's like walking in this like suburban
neighborhood and his fucking bear.
He's on two legs, like a dude in a
bear outfit like Yogi. Really? Yeah,
and I mean he walks 30 40 yards like this.
So if you were in the woods and you
saw this bear doing that, he'd be like,
I saw a fucking Sasquatch. I know what
I saw. Especially if it was like dusk.
You know, look at this bear. Look at
him. You got to be kidding me. No,
check them out man.
Pull it.
Pull it from the beginning so we
could see the whole thing. ABC News.
Look at this. Oh yeah man. I mean
if you didn't know any better,
especially if it's thick
woods and you saw that thing,
you would fucking swear that that's the,
the shots you're looking at,
right there are often about, as long
as you see a bear. Yeah, look at him.
Look at that. Look at that.
That is fucking crazy.
That's pretty wild that you
like to get around like that.
You would assume that that is a monkey.
That's an ape.
That's a fucking bear.
No.
Does he have a normal gait when
he does get down on all fours?
He screwed up some who's
running? Oh, he was,
you saw him run on all four paws
or injured. Oh, his paws injured.
Or you might've got trap.
No, no, no, not both.
Pause. Just like, right Paul.
It looks like he's right.
Pause one states in New Jersey.
Yeah.
I mean if he got caught in a trap is
because someone illegally set, mm.
I don't think that's the car.
I mean you can't trap bears in New Jersey,
but just the fact that a bear has that
ability, I can trap it all in New Jersey.
I don't know if there's some fur trapping
there, but I don't know to what extent,
but there's no bear trapping there.
It isn't impossible that he got caught
in another animal's trap and that's how
he's still alive because he only ever law.
There's no trap that would
be used for bearing animals
now that would cripple that thing
to the point where he would do that.
If he got caught and a
foothold trap or leg old trap,
he would pop his foot out of there.
Really? I mean, I can't, like,
I can't rule out everything.
If that's what happened to that bear.
And I have no reason to think
that it is. Um, if that,
if like if someone came down and said,
absolutely that's what happened
to that bear, I'd be like,
then someone was doing like an illegal
trapping active because that's not
something that would happen.
Is it much more likely she,
cause we were looking at a resident
like clap do it on something,
but I could put my ice to
do this when I used to trap,
I used to do this all time is you know,
I can snap my hand in most traps really
now cause the tramp has more of a
function of,
I mean this is going to get all,
you're going to probably hear
from all kinds of your listeners,
but it has a holding function.
So it starves to death.
No, not, not if you're, no, because
you have to check your traps.
Oh, so you go there and it's still
alive. Then you have to kill it. Yeah.
So when I suffered trip,
I would check my traps every 24 hours,
usually in the morning,
you know. But anyways,
what the trap large serves to do is
hold something and the way when you rig
them, if you do things right, okay,
you ring them with a lot of swivels and
things and so what you're trying to do
is really limit any kind
of damage to the animal.
And this isn't altruistic.
The reason you want to limit damage to
the animal is the animals less likely to
fight the trap. Okay. If
you have a trap that causes,
that causes nerve damage,
bone damage, numbing,
okay.
It's all the more chances that that thing
is going to be working harder to get
away and to thinking is that in the ideal
case, you're just trying to hold it.
We're the foothold trap. So in what you're
thinking does everybody, they, yeah,
people want to say chew, but what they
will do, and I've, you know, I have,
I've seen it happen, particularly
the Muskrat's which have
very, very thin bones.
There's one only has one. Paul wonder
what happened to him? Where's that?
I have no idea. I just typed in
bear trap. That's hog service.
What do you think happened there?
Well that's,
that's too high on his leg
to be a trap. Yeah. So you,
maybe that's a shot,
a gunshot or something like that.
Then he could have gotten shot.
He could've got shot.
He could've got hit by a car. He
could've got gotten. I mean, you know,
I mean things we meet such
weird ends and injuries.
I've seen bears it, I'm fairly
convinced on Prince of Wales Island,
I've seen bears that I'm fairly convinced
had been shot just because of the sort
of like where on the shoulder
it happened, you know? Right.
Like it looked like someone look like,
I just be like,
I could picture how that would happen.
I can't say that that didn't happen there,
but I wouldn't, that's not a trap thing.
What I asked you with muskrats anyways,
most guys have very,
very,
very thin bones and you'll see where
you'd get must grass. It would,
in trapper parlance,
they'll say it would ring out.
So we'll just twist and get away, you
know. Oh, okay. So it just keeps spinning.
And so people say like a chew out,
but it's weird because people
who people defending trapping,
we'll like to clarify this. Not
actually chew off. It's a ring on,
but they're still cutting
their own arm off. Yeah,
I spinning around until the tissue.
I never saw it. I saw it on,
um, Muskrat's I never
saw it on larger animals.
I know, I'm not saying that it
doesn't happen, but again, like,
like everything, there's a, there's a
sort of, there's good practices. Okay.
I don't travel anymore so I'm not,
I don't have like, uh, when I,
when I tell you what I'm telling you,
I'm just telling you this from being a
guy who likes to be clear about factual
matters. I'm not, I don't have like
a real dog in the race on this,
so to speak right now.
But when,
if you follow good practices on trapping,
okay.
You, it's in your best interest to not
have these sorts of things happen that you
would set in away that you don't
have incidental catches for bycatch.
Right. You check your traps on
a very tight schedule. You know,
you read them in such a way
that you don't cause damage,
that if you did get something
else into your trap,
you would be able to release that thing
unharmed. But there are people who,
for lack of caring and there are people
who just for lack of technical expertise,
screw these things up.
You know,
and oftentimes you could get violations
like what would be like a trapping based
violation from someone who wouldn't self
identify as a fur trapper but who just
got mad about some bear or
whatever getting into his
dumpster and then he takes
matters into his own hands completely
outside of the law and decides to like fix
that bear and an expert lease at
a trap for it. You know, delve,
there are bear traps right though.
Chaps,
you seen those movies at catch the bad guy
in his leg and he's screaming, ah, Yup.
Those are real. Those are, I mean there,
there used to be a lot of
black bear trapping, you know,
people use trap blackberries all the time.
There used to be some
grizzly trapping at a time.
People would trap them to sell for, they
trap them to get them for, you know,
scientific purposes.
They,
they'd trap them to just catch them for
pets they trap and to mitigate livestock
risk. You know, there's a lot
of traveling going on right now.
Bear trapping. Um, [inaudible]
isn't a thing that goes out.
There's not like there's a bear
trap went there. Yeah. Yeah.
And what's funny now is that there
used to be a lot of bear traps,
antique bear chaps on the market,
but people still manufacturer.
What would,
what would be a bear trap in order to
sell it as a like as a piece of memory?
Like a false memorabilia. Oh,
like a Flint lock gun. Exactly.
So there's a lot of guys that make re
like reproductions of old bear traps.
There's no like,
no one's like intending that they're
going to go set it for a bear.
But people want to have like a lodge.
You know,
you've got like your cabin and you wanna
have a big bear trap hanging up in it,
right? So there's a lot of bear traps and
you'll see where a doodle think he has
something,
you know
when he's trying to sell it for 1000
bucks and you look at and be like,
you could go buy those all day long
for $150. It just like, it's not old.
There's a comedy club in town called the
Improv and the front of the Comedy Club
at one time they've abandoned it,
but it was a barbecue place
and the barbecue place,
they tried to make it like with old
tools and the wall like an old saw,
like you know those
wooden handle on each side
and you could look at it and you're like,
I know that shit. It's two years old.
Like I'm looking at,
it's all rusty and everything,
but I know this is not a fucking antique.
They had a one of those sickles that you
know, like the, the death dealer that uh,
w, what do they call it?
The depth grim reaper.
Grim reaper is always supposed to
have that was on the wall to it.
Trying to make it like some
farm. Oh yeah. Old timey.
Old timey wood walls, like
a stain, you know, like uh,
like they made it look like it's old
and weathered, you know the wood,
which summit mean? This is actually
from 100 year old farm house.
The wood that we have here. This is
reclaimed oak. This is nice. Yeah.
I specifically went out of the way to get
old would cause I felt like it be kind
of cool,
you know,
because it's probably some weird
energy in some old farm would.
And this is like real old thick wood.
Oh yeah. No, I like it. I have the,
me and my old man cut down. He's dead
now. But when I was in high school,
he was building a pole
barn and we cut down oak
on this piece of property we owned
across the road from our house.
It's the little corner lot.
And we cut down to,
oh he built the barn and
I took that. Oh, the logs.
And I took them down and put them on
a flatbed trailer and had a milled in
lumber. Oh Wow. And it took
all that lumber and years
later he's been dead since.
I think 2002 2003 I still
haven't finished this,
but then I laminated all those pieces
together and to like what looks like
chunks of Bowling Lane.
Ah,
I'm still trying to make a damn desk
out of these things. Oh Wow. It's like,
and I'm actively engaged right now.
I'm trying to move one of these slabs
from miles city out to Washington now so I
can continue my now 12 year long project
or trying to turn me in the old man's
tree. So anyways, I'm, I'm a
sentimentalist when it comes to wood,
just like yourself. Oh, that's cool. So
you're going to make it like writing desk,
like where you do your writing?
I think so.
I think I'm gonna make a ramp around
us. Gal. That's a great idea. Yeah.
But all the pieces I have together on
his biggest, his desk or sitting at,
but it's still a nice big chunk.
I have a desk that I bought in 1993 it's
a writing desk and it's got two levels,
like one level. It's a very,
it's old, it's oak, you know,
but it's like there was a place called
the writer's store and it was a store in
Hollywood that was just all writing stuff
needs to have like script programs for
old school Max.
Like you know the oldest computing muses,
1994 that I got this fucking thing and
I've written everything I've ever written
on this one desk still. No. Yeah, I won't.
I will ever get rid of it. My wife's like,
let's get rid of this piece of shit.
I'm like, get the fuck Outta here.
This does desk going nowhere. It's solid
as a rock. It's all oak, but it's just,
there's stains on it. She said it's
disgusting. Got like coffee. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. This shit's perfect.
Like as long as it's in my office,
you fucking leave it. He has got the
Patina of your a sweat and labor.
Everything good I've ever
written is all from that desk.
This is one desk I've had and
I'm never getting rid of it.
I've just got this one oak desk that I've
had from the beginning of my time here
in La and I'll never get rid of that.
Fuck. So when you say that you've written,
do you sit down and write? Yes.
Stand up. Well, I sit down and write,
this is what I do.
Most of the time I write,
like I used to keep an active
blog on my website, but um,
when I started writing a book,
I got a book deal a few years
back and I started writing a book.
I stopped writing the blog and then when,
uh,
the publishers were
just fucking trying to,
they were essentially trying to
get me to write it, like, stand up.
I remember you talking about, yeah.
So I gave them their money back.
What'd you fell like? Doesn't work
for a book. Well, I don't like it.
Like I've read,
I've read like George Carlin's book,
which is essentially just his stand up in,
in book form.
And Jerry Seinfeld did a similar thing.
I don't like that. I, if I'm gonna,
if I want George Carlin's writing
like that, I want to see it.
I want to see George Carlin do is to,
I don't want to read it.
And then there's some benefit I guess
and breeding it. There's some, it's good,
it's better than nothing, but it's
not as good as when I, when I write,
I'm writing stuff because I know
people are going to read it, you know?
So the descriptive, a very different, the
way it's spaced out is very different.
The way I set things up
is different. And so, um,
what I do now is I write as if I was
going to write a book or a blog entry and
then I go over it and then I extract
ideas that come out of that because I feel
like I do both.
Like I'll write down specifically,
I'll try to write as a joke, like thinking
I'm standing on stage and you know,
set up punchline or beginning
premise and then add in the jokes.
But more often I just write
like I'll write about something.
And then along the way, usually
I'm baked. So it's, I get silly,
like as I'm writing,
like these new ideas will come in and
I'll just deal with characters and stuff.
No, no, no. Just writing as you were told
that sometimes you write as you talking.
Yeah, I right. Not even as me talking,
I just write like I'll
write like, uh, like,
uh, pick a subject like, um,
whatever amphetamines,
pissed speed, you know,
Adderall and I'll start writing about
Adderall. And then along the way,
you know,
I'll have like a really funny thing
will come up in the writing or like,
like I'm laughing as I'm writing it
because it just came out of nowhere.
Did you feel like you're a really
good writer, Matt, by the way?
I really loved mediator, so
really good book. Oh, thanks
man. It's a, and it was, uh,
I mean, I knew you're a smart dude and
you're, you're obviously very articulate,
but the writing was very, it's very
descriptive. It's very interesting.
It's very fun to follow. And when you, um,
when you write stuff like that,
don't you feel like sometimes,
like as you're writing,
like it's almost like it's not even you
that's writing like these ideas just
sorta like pop into your head,
like out of nowhere and then
you're putting them down?
No. Um, um, for me,
I'm so aware of the process that
there's no surprising thing to me.
One of my mentors and what,
like what I regard as one of the best
American nonfiction writers out there
alive now as a, as a writer named
Ian Frazier. And what's his work?
He's got several books. One of the
books I hold, it was just like,
you're one of the,
in my opinion,
one of the finest books ever written as
his book. Great Plains, great plains,
which is about the great plains. Um,
but he's, he's a stylist, you know,
he's also a, he was a humor writer for
the New Yorker for a long time. It was,
I had great fortune to, you know,
he, he know if he would use his term,
I think he'd like
mentored me in somewhere.
I read his stuff and had the opportunity
to hang out with him a handful of times.
And then he was saying that when he was
growing up and you wanted to be a writer,
he pictured the writers would be that
you're sitting at a desk kind of chuckling
to yourself as you, you know,
have all these fantastic ideas.
But when I write,
I get so few words written every day
and every sentence that I write takes,
I have to write it and rewrite it and
rewrite it so many times that there's
never a thing where I feel like, um,
there's never a thing where I feel like,
holy smokes, I nailed it
because it's, it's, so,
I almost look at it like if
you're building a house, you know,
maybe when you get all done with the
house, you can stand outside and be like,
wow, there it is. I did it
right. But there's never,
there's never a shocking moment because
every nail and every board, you know,
there's never a chance for where
something jumps ahead radically,
really quickly in a way they
can start with you. Now,
the other night I wrote my brother's
getting married this weekend.
My older brother and I sat down
to to make some notes about,
um, I'm gonna, you know,
my best man speech right after
I wrote my best man's speech.
It's funny because this just happened to
me last night after I did my best man's
speech. I felt like, why can't I
feel like I had it where I got,
I was like talking about some funny
stuff in my head and kind of writing down
notes and I thought of some way to
actually like you're supposed to doing the
best man speech is you're supposed
to make it like hit right?
Like hit the right note.
It's funny and your dog and on them
and then all of a sudden you turn it,
you know, and it's sweet and nice. Okay.
And I found that turn to make
it sweet and nice and it's so,
and it just struck me as being like
perfect, you know? And I was like,
why can't the regular writing? I do
feel that way. That's interesting.
Where I'm like, Huh. You know, and I kind
of want to like pump my fist in the air.
Whether people that, you know, that our
writers have those moments with those,
those uh, those moments that I'm talking
about where things just pop to you.
I feel like they do. I, I, you know,
one of the things that I follow on
Twitter is this thing I'm John Winokur and
it's just,
I don't know how he does it,
but six or seven times a day he's got
quotes from great writers about writing.
How do you spell his name? J. O.
H. N. W. I. N. O man. John Winokur.
It's like writers on writing.
And I learned more about writing and
writers from reading this thing cause it's
like really cool writers talking
about the writing process.
I'm sure he's probably hit one just
within minutes. Oh, at advice to writers,
advice to writers had you, uh, like here
right now. Just it, it minutes ago. Um,
or a couple of hours ago when I write,
I don't think of the audience after the
fact. I think, well I hope they like it.
So that's like, oh, writer
talking about writing. Right.
And this Twitter feed hits
these quotes all day long.
So I learned more about writers,
even though I went to writing
school and everything,
I learned more about writers
following that guy's Twitter account.
And I do get that some writers are
blown away and have fun writing.
To me it's agonizing.
I can't stand it.
That's a weird thing about doing
TV is I love having written,
you know, when I write a book, I'm so,
it's just like a deep,
deep satisfaction. Okay.
I love having done it when I die,
if they will,
if they chisel writer into my tombstone,
you know, I, I'd be very happy. Right.
But I hate the act of writing.
Make a TV is so fun.
Just in the moment. It's very fun. I
love going out and doing it, you know?
But when it's said and done,
I don't get that,
that feeling like I slayed the dragon.
Like I would get from writing a book.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
You know, you're, when you're
doing a television show also,
it's very different than most TV.
And that you're out there doing
something you enjoy anyway. Exactly.
And there's a lot of people coming in on
it. So writing is like me. I mean sure.
You know you have it. I don't mean to in
any way discount the role of an editor.
And I don't know if you do
something similar with your standup,
you show other comedians and stuff,
but you have like a role of an editor.
So I don't want to act like, oh, it's
just all out of your head. You know,
my agent I work closely with, he
influences things. I do my header,
but, and yet it's kind of,
it's your thing, right?
TV's a whole bunch of people so you could
go out and have a great thing and then
you turn it in and the,
and the editor nails it.
So I can't go like I made this amazing
TV show because it's like there's the guy
that produced it, the guys that
shot the guys edited it, right.
All that kind of stuff.
And so you're a sense of ownership
becomes a little bit different.
You're like a stake holder and not
like the dude that owns the thing.
Yeah. There's so much going on. There's
music, there's the way it's edited.
Oh extremely.
It really has a massive impact on how
it comes off as a, as a piece. Yeah.
I think like as a host, you know, as
a host and as a person who has like a,
a lot of sway in the kinds of things we
go do, I still feel like I'm, you know,
I'm kicking in 10 or 20% and 80 90% is,
you know, a handful of other
people who are throwing in on it.
Nobody works harder than
people who work on your show.
Like those kinds of dudes like Doty
and Mo and all those guys who have to
fucking sleep in tents and in the back
of that fucking van where the lamas
pissed and
I really kind of love it.
I love those guys was fine. We just
had this guy, we wound up liking him.
We had a camera guy to come out with us
for the first time and then he was just
getting beat up. I mean, it'd
be he admitted it, you know,
and it kind of became the joke where he's
saying the Dougherty, he's like, man,
you guys gotta do a better job
of explaining what this is.
And Dan's like, I feel like I said,
it's like rigorous hiking, you know?
And he's like, yeah, but
like that's not this.
I thought like walking on a trail
or something, you know, it's like,
but there's no language to explain it.
I don't know why those guys,
well I do know why I think
one could look and be like,
I don't understand why those guys would
subject themselves to that right level
of treatment.
Because I've had the opportunity to
work very briefly in what would be like
network television, mainstream
television. And I'm telling you what,
that's not typical.
What you do,
what those guys do and the
hours they do it is not typical.
Not at all.
No.
I was shocked here like one time some
guy was coming out with us and I knew it
was gonna be trouble because
he's come out of this.
He's asking about what the hours are. And
I'm like, I don't know. I think, you know,
we usually we'll sleep at night
24 hours a day or that hours.
It's like,
what do you mean when you're sleeping
on the ground in Montana and it's zero
degrees outside and you're
fucking huddled up in your tent,
you're kind of working,
still owe it because you would never be
there unless they were paying you to be
there. Like even though
you're off, we'd still,
you're subjecting yourself to sleeping
on the ground in Montana in a tent and
you're freezing your dick off.
You know,
like you have to like flex and squeeze
under your sleeping bag to degenerate
some warm before he can pass out.
You're kind of working. Yeah. Like that.
Like Dougherty Yanis Mo. I, they just,
okay.
Uh, they just, they like to be in some
way tortured a little bit, I think.
And they also just like to be working, you
know, I don't, I don't think that they,
but the other thing is, I don't
think they really, they're at work,
but I don't know how much they
think about being at work.
I see what you're saying. I think they
just think of it as like existing, whoa,
Jimmy. I don't think they go
like, oh no, I'm going to work.
I think that they think of their
lives more. Their lives don't seem to,
I don't think they think of their
lives and having like, it's like, no,
I'm at work now. I'm at home
now, I'm at work now I'm at home.
I think like at home they're thinking
about work stuff and uh, okay.
Do you know what I mean? I feel like more
there that they don't look at it like,
you know, punching the old clock is
my guess. They of, well it was funny
cause Mo and I had a conversation once
about another show that he was working on
and one of the guys that was
on the other show and uh,
he was taking great pride in
describing what a coward this guy was.
And it was, it was not even great pride,
but he was enjoying it. He's like,
he's yellow. He was talking
about it, but it was like,
here's a guy that's been working on
your show for several seasons and he's
fucking undergone some
horrendous locations and
climbing to the top of fucking
mountains while carrying a 50 pound
camera and the whole deal. I mean,
these fucking cameras are no joke.
And hiking, just carrying a gun,
hiking is difficult because all it's
sliding of the ground underneath you and
you're constantly going up,
up, up, and you're, you know,
essentially like you're doing like
little mini squats all day long and it's
exhausting.
And these guys are doing it with one
arm holding a fucking camera backwards,
backwards. Like a little joke about
ginger Rogers and Fred Astaire, you know,
like she did everything Fred
Astaire did backwards. Right, right,
right. Yeah. Most too
good though, man. Like,
like we can't like most too
good, you know, he's like, oh,
he's off doing other stuff.
You know, it was like a chain.
It was like a treat to have him,
but he's always trying to win,
but he's just in such demand,
you know what I mean? He's been,
he's nominated for all these
enemies all the time. Yeah.
He won an Emmy nominated
for an Emmy this year. Well,
your show stands out at all.
I mean there's,
there's hunting shows and then
there's your show. And the,
the only show that I've seen
recently that does that as well.
Have you seen uncharted, the Jim
Shockey show? No, but I know a lot of,
I know his stuff. I haven't seen
that, but I know that, that,
that show is a highly respected show.
It's really good.
Her daughter was telling me,
he said, it's phenomenal.
I watched it the other day for the first
time and he was often Pakistan and it
was really intense because one of the
guys that goes with them all the time,
his wife didn't want him go to Pakistan.
I mean,
she was like really scared and she was
like, you know, it's so dangerous there.
Please don't go. He's got a wife and
kids. And so he stayed back and you know,
Jim Shockey went by himself and they
followed the guy who stayed back going on
this trip, um, to hunt deer.
And when he went on this trip at
home in Texas to hunt deer, you know,
he was talking about his dad and like
he the real scene crying and it was,
it was really intense. It was very, very,
very intense. But in a way that you,
you know, like a lot of those
shows are so fucking bad.
Long before I got involved
in TV and outdoor TV,
it was like a thing you would
always hear is friends of mine,
guys I respected would kind of be sort
of dismissing outdoor television as a
genre. But the thing was I was
like, but Shockey's legit or,
or something or some such thing. I mean
he's been around for so long. Yeah.
But he's a,
he's a highly respect to figure it was
this annual thing called shot show and,
and I see him, you can't miss them.
I mean the guy is huge and you know,
he's Kinda like the last great
white hunter, you know, you know,
cowboy hat all the time. I see
him and I want you to, you know,
I always think I'm going to go up and
say something to them. I never had it.
Never had. Oh, I wouldn't, I would force
myself to not ever want to meet that guy.
And there's, there's an
amazing thing. So, uh,
I mean there's just some good
clips and stuff he's done and he's,
he's an articulate guy and goes to
some cool places and he's, you know,
is you can tell his heart's in
the right place, man. I like,
I think he has an honest, you know,
he has an honest affection for,
for wildlife and wild
places. For sure. For sure.
You also enjoys the
roughing and aspect of it.
Like he enjoys going to these ridiculous
remote locations and hunting these very
odd animals is very exotic animals.
He did something when they
flew into Russia and they,
they took these fucking weird
SUV things. He's off. I mean,
I shouldn't even say SUV,
these weird all terrain vehicles.
It looked like these
military vehicles deep, deep,
deep in the mountains like 12 hour drive
and just see how he's been some wild
places to get some fucking weird
ram, you know, it was just,
it was really intense.
It was unexpected.
I just was flipping through the channels
and it came on and I'd seen his other
show before. So this uncharted thing,
I'd seen all these ads for it, but man,
they were in Pakistan and they were,
they had armed guards with him every way.
They went guys with Ak 47
[inaudible] and it was like,
it was pretty intense because it's a
fucking dangerous, dangerous place.
And he's out there wearing the
traditional Muslim garb he wears like the,
the clothes that those people
where you don't want to stand out,
you don't want to stand
out as being a western guy.
He's like the Green Berets man.
Yeah.
So he's wearing their outfits as he's
hunting. It's really intense and you know,
they're off in the fucking middle of,
I mean deep in the middle of nowhere
hunting some ram. That's great. I'm glad.
I'm glad you like that show
cause it's good to hear, uh,
you know something out there that
caught your eye. It's really well done.
It's really well done. But this is
like that show your show and then like,
you know,
the rest of them are,
there's some of them look like they're
made with like a home movie camera and
it's like a guy who has never even
thought about making a show. Sometimes.
That's true man.
There's a guy,
there's a guy I was talking to who
makes the hunch show and one day we're
talking and I was shocked
to hear that he's a,
he's a registered nurse as a full
time job at a hospital. Whoa. And He,
you know, he makes a hunting show. He
just burns it up man. And he's like, wow,
he's just something he wants to
do and he's just get double times.
Just finds a way to make it happen.
It's fucking hard. Some of them too,
it's like there's some of them
that are the same show always,
which is so bizarre. Yeah.
We, that's the thing,
we have a conversation about his is,
um,
I wanted to go back and
in film next spring.
Um, I have, uh, a black bear
permit for this regulatory year,
which extends in the next spring for
Prince of Wales. I wanted to go back and,
and Doherty was saying it's like anything
that, you know, we did a show out there,
interrupt the mountain story.
We did a show out on Prince Wales last
spring and went and found a lot of bears
and um, I, in the end I
could have shot a bear.
I didn't because I just have this
strange feeling and sometimes not strange
sometimes doesn't want to watch
bears rather than shoot at them.
So we did a show about that and
okay.
I wanted to go back this
spring and dirty was like,
I just feel like anything we could have
done out there, we've done, you know,
and then one and I'm
like, yeah, that's right.
We probably shouldn't go and do a show
an episode in the same place doing the
same thing but then are having like
Bahamas cause some shows. All it is,
they don't do anything but hunt there
like some lease they have for whitetail
deer every single time. Yeah. Yeah.
Show is looking at camera photos
from camera traps and them, you know,
talking about the different stands that
they have set up and then them up in the
stand with a bow and arrow waiting
for a fucking deer to come by. I mean,
that is every goddamn show. It's always
whitetail. It's always in a tree stand.
It's always in the same sort of farmland
on the edges of these cornfields.
And it's the same show
every God damn week.
And I guess people just like watching
people hunt deer. Do you enjoy it?
I watch, I watch him, you know, every now
and then I like, you know, thinking like,
Ooh, I wish I saw that deer and I was that
close. I'll shoot the shit out of that.
Yeah. Like you'd learn a bunch
of stuff eventually watching
it. Yeah, he definitely
learn stuff.
You learn stuff about wind and placement
and the trails they walk and their
behavior, like how they, you know,
how they can kind of anticipate where
they're coming through and how to,
how to pay attention to their trails. And
one of them, uh, well it was interesting.
Uh, it was, uh,
how to recognize the difference between
the doe trails and the buck trails.
So the doe trails,
we're going straight across this like
this a riverbed area where there's a lot
of mud and you could see like these dose
that like large populations of animals
going this way and he's like, you see
these animals that are criss crossing?
Those are, those are bucks catching the
scent and catching the sene of these.
Yeah.
Does that, I hadn't heard that. Oh really?
Oh, that's interesting. That was subtle.
No, I don't know a ton about what
I mean. I grew up on white tails.
We grew up hunting white tails,
not probably using our heads as
much as we might have, you know.
Well, the one, yeah, we got, we got deer.
Yeah. Yeah. The time we went. Right.
Doug's farm in Wisconsin, man, my
fucking deer. They're everywhere.
Yeah. It's crazy. And they're, you're
not playing. This is the distinction.
Hours make in hunting is
okay.
I tried to find those places where you're
mostly thinking about animals and not
so much thinking about hunters.
Well you
just on that, on your show
too though, the difference,
like the one time that you went and you
were elk hunting in Montana and you know,
you were on your way after an elk and
you see another fucking hunter that's
doing the same thing,
multiple everywhere.
Yeah.
So you spend most of your time wondering
about what other guys are doing and
then trying to capitalize on that or
trying to anticipate the response of
animals to that pressure.
You know,
I so much rather just be like in a one
on one thing next week we're going off to
hunt Moose up in the Brooks
range now and it's one of the,
you know, absolutely the most,
one of the most remote places,
the most remote place in North America.
And I'm up there. It's like
there's really no, you don't, I,
you don't have to factor in
effects of other individuals.
You're just thinking about the animals,
which is fun and it's very rewarding,
but it's just not what
most people are up against.
Like when I was a kid and we're hunting
white tails, we really planned on,
um, people, you know, it was very
important about where all their guys were,
what other guys hunting
schedules was like, you know, um,
there's certain guys we knew that,
you know,
there's a guy we knew that
would always say like,
if I see your guys' truck coming
down the driveway to the farm,
I always go over to such and such place
because I know that the way you guys
move into your blinds, your likely to
bump a deer down such and such fence line.
So this guy's thinking about deer shirt.
He's thinking about it through the
context of, of human activities.
So dear being scared by you.
And he's like,
you guys got that blind down in that area.
And I know every time you go in there you
don't realize it because you're a dumb
ass.
But when you go in there,
you're bumping deer and they're
going down that fence line.
So if I see your truck coming
on and run over there, wow.
Which is a kind of thing.
And like elk when I lived in Montana,
we would like,
our opening day plan was
generally find out where elk are,
where they've been for a couple of weeks
and so that people will know they're
there.
How are they going to leave that area
within three minutes of legal shooting
light on opening day and what saddle are
they going to use in a pass out of that
valley and you would pretty much plan
that would be your thing is I know where
they're at.
I know that they're going to get bumped
probably before legal light and where
are they going to go after that?
I got a friend who has for the last,
you know,
20 years man killing elk by
he.
He knows the spot to elk move into when
they get pressured and he knows it.
Some people can find these elk with
spotting scopes and they'll find these elk
on his mountain side.
He knows that you,
there's no way to approach these elk on
his mountain south without spooking him.
When he sees the elk have
moved into this area,
he'll watch him with a spot and scope
waiting to see someone else try to climb
up and put a move on. These elk when
they start climbing up act when he goes,
that guy sees him, he's going to
go and try to put a move on him.
He'll go down an ambush, those elk
three miles away from there. Wow.
And he waits till someone sees him cause
he knows what we're going to go cause
he knows the path they always take with
me and he calls it the laundry chute
cause he said they come spilling through
there like laundry, laundry chute.
He's been doing it for 20 years.
Wow.
I really enjoyed that episode that
you did this year in Kentucky. Yeah.
That you went elk hunting in Kentucky
because the situation is very,
it's very unique in that they've
reintroduced successfully
reintroduce elk into
Kentucky and
instead of like what you're looking at
a western hunt where you look at these
great wide open spaces and timber and
you could see them in the distance.
Instead,
you're looking at an incredibly dense,
like southeast sort of kind of
forests where these elk are like,
you were like kind of creeping up on him
and it was hard for the camera guy to
get a good view of some of
these Alpha at the Lq shot.
Like there's so many God damn trees there.
Oh yeah.
You're just seeing little portions of,
it was funny because when that
show in the beginning of that show,
we're standing there and uh,
you know,
predawn darkness and there's
like the eastern forest,
they're sort of like the cacophony of
noise and an eastern forest that you lack
in the west, it's lugs and towing. The
bio diversity is so much higher, you know,
not a large mammals, but the biodiversity
of just stuff that Zach has a moisture,
I don't know, quality is
soil moisture probe. Yeah,
I would guess moisture as a huge part
of it and probably the for fertility,
the landscape, like, like the,
you know how nutrient rich the soil is
at some base level probably is what's at
play. Climate northwest doesn't have
those sounds and it's very moist.
Yeah, you're right. That's
why I was confusing.
I know guys that would be able
to answer that. I, I dunno. I,
I know that for instance,
I keep coming back around,
you can tell I'm so excited about
our hunt on principles. Alex had all,
my brother who is an ecologist up there,
um,
that that elevation band were
Prince of Wales Island. Is,
is sort of the,
the richest marine environment
of anywhere. Really. Yeah. So that,
that like latitude band is an extremely
rich marine environment there as far as
the fishing there must be
incredible. Yeah. And just,
I mean it's just everything.
It's like, it's just a buzz
with life. Are we going to,
we're going to fish there were there
were there too? No, no, no. If we get,
maybe there's a possibility, but probably
not. So it gets a little bit late.
Like fishing peaks like July, August
is phenomenal. It just kind of halibut.
Yeah.
But they held,
it's so much better in July and August
and we were just up there for my
brother's Bachelor party and did
phenomenally well. Unhealed. But yeah,
Doug was sending me pictures. We
got some doozies norm some, yeah,
some nice tables.
So in the beginning,
that episode just kind of
standing there and um, and,
and to hear that noise of
the eastern forest, you know,
and then to have it be that
you're looking for elk is so,
it just feels weird for anyone to
live with that and hold up a clip,
pull up a clip.
So people get here cause it's pretty cool.
It's you in the forest like on
your show where you were, uh,
you were explaining it
and talking about it.
The smell,
smell,
smell right now seems to
have like a warm to him.
It's hard to explain, but you just kind
of guess that too. Like you'll smell it.
Not word outcome words were
used,
his power games,
bed bed,
little bats all over here.
It just makes sense.
Yeah, those things are cool. It's like
a ghost in the forest. He shows up.
There they are. Man, this is so
different. So what norm is too.
So they'll say he's got wiped
out of that area by eight,
1820. Um, and you're
like, Daniel Boone, uh,
used to cross over to get down
into the Kentucky hunting grounds.
He would cross over to Cumberland gap,
which is very near there.
And then he would go to, you know,
what we call the blue grass hills.
And that was an more open environment and
had a lot of elk and people would hunt
in Houston,
not the blue grass hills for elk,
deer hunt for deer and a hundred for
black bear selling the meat and heights by
1820 or thereabouts, the
elk herd has gone. Okay.
The buffalo got shot out. Um, elk
got shot out, dear remained black,
remained mountain lions were shot out,
wolves are shot out and they were
gone for over a hundred years.
And then when they did it,
all that mountaintop coal
mining in Kentucky and after
the reclamation process,
you know, they had chopped down in
the construction of these minds,
they destroyed a lot of, of
hardwood forests. Okay. Like
deciduous hardwood forest,
Hickory Beach, oh work, all kinds of
stuff. But when they reclaimed the left,
all these flat mountain top areas that
they just did it. And, and, um, you know,
grasses and other stabilizing vegetation,
not timber.
And it created sort of this open
savanna like environment and
people recognize it to be
a good place to put elk.
And there wasn't a lot of resistance if
you went into an agricultural area and
decided, you know, we got a great idea,
we're going to bring
in thousands of seven,
800 pound herbivores and
cuddle loose out here.
You would get a ton of resistance.
But the areas rural enough and,
and the reclaim coal country,
that just wasn't a huge interest
in not putting them there.
And so now they've got the biggest
elkert east of the Mississippi.
There's 10,000 plus elk
run around and Kentucky,
but even still al-kurd are
like 90% not recovered,
you know, I mean, they were
everywhere. They were everywhere.
And the weird thing about it
is we could have as many back,
we could totally bring back
way more than we have now.
But you have a handful of
interest that don't like that.
Auto insurers generally don't like it.
Agricultural interest don't like it,
but it's one of those things that we
could fix like that. And the Buffalo,
the only thing standing between us and
restoring buffalo to more of their native
range is popular conception,
perception of, you know, property,
the perception of the issue.
The only thing standing between Austin
reintroducing elk to more and more of
their native range is just selling it
to the public. Other problems we have,
you know, you look at something
like acidification of the
oceans, people are like,
she's, I have no idea. I Dunno
what I, there's no way, right?
It's impossible to fix this.
It's too expensive. Whatever.
We don't know the science,
we don't understand the science of it,
but some stuff like when it comes
to bringing big animals back,
oftentimes it's just a matter
of do we want to or not?
And in Kentucky there was enough people
that want it to where they made it
happen and now it's a thriving hurt.
They're even using that herd they had,
they pulled animals.
The Rocky Mountain Elk
Foundation spearheaded the
saying and provided much the
money and labor for it.
They pulled animals from Kimra for
[inaudible] 17 or 20 source sites,
moved him into Kentucky. Now Kentucky's
a source site for other reintroduction.
So they're pulling animals out of
Kentucky now and use them to, to,
to reintroduce herds and all the
places where they were extubated.
But what other places are they planning
it now? They've got some going into,
I know in Virginia to bring in some in,
um,
I'm not sure if they brought
them in in North Carolina,
but North Carolina had an aid of hurts.
Was this an amazing animal?
So the meat is so incredibly healthy.
It's really like a, a, a breast,
a pound of chicken and a pound of elk.
The elk will have last cholesterol.
It's healthier for you,
less fat, more protein.
It's the best. It's the best meat
out there man. As far as eating,
like the taste of visit is still make,
there's no bad elk.
They're just good. Even the big
giant ones. There's this good man.
My brother killed one one time. He
had a really hard, it was just tough.
He had an age, but you just, you know,
you need like a nice facility to be able
to consistently age stuff cause the,
if the weather's against you, you can't
age. Like we're, you know, no one's got,
most people don't have a walking
cooler where they can go hang 400,
500 pounds of meat. That is what an
elk. So if you get one in, it's hot.
Oftentimes you've got to get it into a
freezer and it'll age a little bit in the
freezer. But anyways, he killed one
flavor was great, but it was just a tough,
tough,
tough bowl to chew on.
Just a big muscular animal and it's just
tough. And um, it was funny cause he uh,
he started the, the only vegetable
he was interested in eating.
I'm going to tell you this was
boiled cabbage because he's like,
I only have so much muscle power and
my jaw and I can't waste any of my jaw
muscle power on anything
but chewing my elk.
So he would eat boiled cabbage and that,
and his elk until he got done
with it until he saw crowns.
Let me tell you a funny start on this
guy to like his aversion to waste is a
buddy of ours got married one time and
and his bride's neighbors were out of
town for during the wedding ceremonies.
The bride's neighbor says,
well,
I'll open my house up if you some out
of town guests who need a place to stay
because I'm on vacation anyways,
so they give this house where it's just
like for the groomsmen to hang out.
I mean, my brothers were in the, you know,
were the groomsmen and
some other guys and stuff.
We get to stay in this house
during our stay. He has Okasan.
My brother Matt has occasion to peak
in the guy's freezer and sees in his
freezer that he's got an elk
he killed four years ago.
It's dated from four years ago and he,
he has a moral crisis where he's like,
is it worse to steal or is it worse to
allow such a beautiful animals flesh to
go to waste when this guy inevitably will
declare this freezer burned and throw
it away. Like if he was going to eat it,
he would hate it. Right. Three years ago,
three and a half years ago,
so when we left he had a bunch of that
in his duffel bag and went home and ate
it because he couldn't stomach the
thought of that animal going to waste like
his reverence for it is so
high that he can't have,
he can't allow someone else to,
to trifle with it.
How many years is an animal good in
a freezer? I'm telling you what man.
It depends on the animal lean
stuff like elk if you trim away.
Okay. Lean stuff like hooved animals
who have, who have game animals.
If you trim away the fat, which we don't
call it that, we call tallow, it's waxy.
If you trim that stuff away and you either
seal it with a vacuum sealer and then
don't mess with the bag,
like don't poke any holes in the bag so
that the seal stays good and treat it
very gently so that this deal stays so
the seal stays intact or you wrap it in
Saran wrap and then wrap
it in wax freezer paper.
You could not. Pepsi challenge that
stuff. If it was a year old again,
stuff that was a month old. What about
two years? Three years I've done that too.
Two is for me personally,
the longest out I've gone is to,
I've heard of people going more and at
two when you thought and you look at it,
you can tell something happened to it
where you can trim it up and have it be
and I've served at old stuff
like that to my wife. No time.
It happens to me is if I wind up having
something get kind of lost in my freezer.
If you don't practice good freezer
management like I try to do,
what would it be last
in, first out, right.
But now and then just something happens
and you lose track of something and you
find some old thing.
I've served stuff to my wife that was two
years old and she didn't flag it while
eating it. He was like user
and as an experiment do it.
Cause I mean she'll call me out,
right? She eats more wild game meat.
Most people that, I mean it's, you
know, she's wild game meat every night.
That's all you have in your home or
at home. Yeah, he does. He gave me,
lately we've been eating
salmon and how that,
which you can't really complain about,
but you know, she's eating tons of it.
She'd recently, um, I'm not allowed,
I'm trying to get this overturned,
but right now there's a
moratorium on bear meat
in your house because you've got tricky
knows. Yeah. I saw her, her and my kids.
She said that you will not serve
bear me to my kids. Oh Wow.
Because of you getting, as I got the
word illness, if you under cook it,
it's like 150 degrees. Right. You and know
what it is. And I tried to explain that.
So
w
the, the spring we hunted black bears.
We have blackberries in the Alaska range.
I took a guy hunting who you should
have on the show at some point.
Is it a guy named Work Denver?
And he's a,
okay.
He, he's just leaving the service now.
He's a navy seal commander. And, um,
he wrote a book called Damn few making
the modern seal warrior and you remember
a few years ago that movie act of Valor
came out and was all active duty seals.
He's one of the stars in that movie
and um, took 'em out, bear hunt.
He grew up fishing and like to fish a lot,
hadn't done any hunting but definitely
grew up in the outdoors. And then,
you know, obviously over the last
13, 14 years they've been just,
he's been just consumed by training and
being deployed again and again and again
to Iraq and Afghanistan.
So he hasn't like messed around outside
even those very important him growing up,
he just, like I said, he's
leaving the service now.
I took them out on a hunt and uh,
we went to black bear hunting and Indiana.
We got on this big black bear and called
in with a Predator call and he killed
the bear and we walked home.
It's a big bore, you know,
it's like a six and a half foot bore.
And I said, and we're cutting it up.
And I'm saying to him on camera,
I'm like, I'm telling you what man,
if a bear is going to have trick
knows this is going to be him.
And what I'm talking about
was Montana used to do free.
Uh, they used to do free testing for
trick analysis so you could send in a,
they asked for specifically a golf ball
sized piece of the tongue and you could
send it in to the Msu and an Msu would
send you the results on your bare.
The first bear ever sent in for testing
was from a 17 year old black bear.
Whoa. And that bear meat came back
positive besides steaks and roasts.
I had 83 pounds of ground meat off
that black bear. It was a big bear.
So I said anything and it comes back
and it's positive and once it's positive
you are excused from wanton waste laws.
So it's illegal to waste
game me. Okay. You,
they spell out in great detail what
you're obligated to retain on an animal in
use. There's some areas in Alaska
for instance, where you know,
if you kill a moose you have
to bring the liver home.
It's specified like legally you're
obligated to salvage, deliver.
So they sent a thing saying we're not
going to give you a new bear tag but your
excuse and if you want to discard
the meat you can discard the meat.
And I was like, there's no
way I'm gonna do that. Right.
The only thing worse to me than getting
tricky analysis was it was thrown away
this bear meat.
So I just got to meet thermometer,
a nice one and eight the
whole bear I went on,
I never got another bear tested and
they told me, I read this thing,
we're saying that these,
they did this study Montana where these
two counties in northwest Montana,
they have really high barrier populations
is Lincoln County in Sanders County.
And they said the Dave never
tested a bear from those counties.
That was over six years of age.
The didn't have trick analysis.
So trigger Knowles is just something that
you're not born with it, right? You can,
you eat in fact did meet and you
can track the disease or you know,
and then you wind up
having those little cysts,
the larva and your muscle tissue and it
just is pass along through consumption.
It's the reason you're supposed
to cook pork to well done.
And now it's not really that way anymore.
We say I've gotten to the out of
domestic pork so much because when they,
when they stopped feeding pigs, restaurant
slop, they really cut trick analysis.
Alex, what they realize is when
they're feeding pigs restaurant slop,
you're inadvertently giving them rats and
mice that are sort of caught up in the
cycle of restaurant slop, right.
And Rats and mice are big carriers.
So once they got rid of then once they
made it illegal and they had like only
that the USDA inspected pigs are
feeding on controlled sources,
not stuff from, you know, garbage
pails. I used to wash dishes,
had to summer camp when I was kid in
everyday a pig farmer came and got all the
food scraps and he fed him and
he was selling inspected pork.
So you can't do that now. So now 97%
of the black bear cases, or sorry,
90 some percent of the trick and notices
cases in the u s come from bear meat.
I'm explaining all this to work and the
next day I'm explaining to him another
interesting thing about black for me,
how there's a lot of variability
in black Burmese. Some are great,
some are not so great.
So I'm talking about when I kill a bear,
I'm always really interested to get a
taste of it to see if we're dealing with,
if we got gold or bronze,
right. And we started firing,
it's rain and we start a little
fire and ski rope. Just some pieces,
just the sample it and it's raining
and we're feeding it the firewood and
everything's wet and she's a pain
in the ass trying to get it cooked.
And eventually I kind of peel this
piece apart in my hands. I'm like,
yeah, you know, we're cool,
we're cool. So there's six of us,
we eat it and I don't even think
in there or think about it. Right?
So the next day we cooked some shanks,
but we cook the piss out of the shanks.
Like we make awesome Buco brace shanks
and cook them for five or six hours.
Right. We'd a whole bunch of that, eat
some grayling, eat some rainbow trout,
go home.
A month goes by and I get
the shits real bad. So,
and it's like a weird kind of the shits.
So I send a text message to
the guys at work with St.
Does anybody have like a weird kind of
the shits because I'm worried that we got
GRD or something or Crypto spiraea from,
from water contamination and um,
one of the guys rice bag and he says, no,
but man do I got, it's like some pieces,
muscle aches, you know, now.
Yeah, we'll never mind that.
I'm worried about my shit.
You know,
I'm not worried about your problem.
So couple days later I remember I'm like
crossing a street and I'm like, God,
that's a weird feeling in my back.
You know?
And it just got worse and worse and worse,
and eventually texted
this guy and I'm like,
what were you saying about muscle legs?
Dude,
in a while four of us all had it.
And when we started putting it together,
I was like,
we all have the same weird thing.
Intense muscle pain and our calves and
tense muscle pain in our next fevers and
we haven't seen each other for a month.
And we all got sick on
July five so it was like,
this isn't the common cold.
So there's an incubation period a month.
What has you eat?
The only thing that can liberate those
larva from their sis is stomach acid.
So when you consume the meat,
your stomach acid dissolves the
the thing and liberates the larva.
And you've got boys and girls in
there and it takes them forever.
It takes them weeks, they build up their
numbers, you know they get kicking ass.
Then they get into your bloodstream,
larva, do an antibiotic month into it.
The larva start burrowing out of your
vascular system and getting into your
muscle tissue when they start
setting up shop. Oh my God.
So
the CDC gets involved in this.
Um,
I was now in Kings County k and they
sent me a thing recently where no one in
King's county has had like
last year in the whole country.
It was like 11 or 12 cases. The
trick Nelson, the whole country,
no one in King's county had it in four
or five years. The last guy that had, um,
I think a guy and I think
a guy in 2007 or 2011,
I can't remember which,
where's kings county is Seattle area.
He had it from making a
homemade mountain lion jerky,
like the only guy.
So they're all excited and they want me
to give him a piece of the meat and I
give him a piece of that meat.
They come to car and I like go down
and hand them a shank off this bear.
I told her, I said, if you eat
that cookie, you know, and um,
she tests it and they get
back to me while later.
Nothing had 868 larva program,
which
is something like 460,000 larva propound.
Oh my God.
There's these blown up images
of it and it's just like,
it's just larva. So the whole meat,
it's just, it's just an festival. Larva,
Bam. Must be in misery. I
don't know what he's thinking,
but I'm fine now.
So out of the four of us to get sick,
I go down and they say like
in severe cases, you know,
if it attacks your pulmonary system,
but if the larva tech your heart,
there's, you'd take it, there's a
medication you take. Well, I said, well,
I'm just gonna take the medication, you
know? And they're like, well, you know,
you might not need to. I said, well, I'll
take it. I go down on that medications,
$2,400 even with health insurance,
it's $1,100 to buy the medication.
So the other guys are like, well,
I'll just wait and see
what happens to you.
We all get better at the same time and
that medication only kills them in your
stomach. Right? So for six to 10 years,
depending on your source,
if you were to eat me under cooked,
you would contract.
Trigonal says,
Whoa,
I don't know if that means
I have 868 larva per gram.
I just have a hard time fathoming that.
But we're all positive,
like we're positive carriers.
Wow.
So you right now have those
things in your muscle tissue.
That's my understanding, and I read
a lot about this as you can imagine.
Like I was very curious about,
I didn't know.
I always thought when you got tricking
analysis, you died kind of. I didn't know.
I thought,
I don't know what I thought.
I've been writing about this and
talking about this on TV for 10 years,
telling people in by the way,
make sure to, but you know,
they say familiarity breeds complacency.
You know I what? It was contempt.
Is that what it is? Yeah. No.
Well then that's my new saying
because I felt like,
I don't know why I can sit here right now
and picture the piece of meat that I'm
sure it got me sick, so I don't
know what else. Thinking, man,
my wife's like is so embarrassing.
She's like,
you're supposed to be like the
mediator and you. I'm like, I'm like,
you know what though? And I was
embarrassed and it's embarrassing, right?
But at the same time, like, you know
what word while the mountain here's die,
they die on the mountain, you
know? So it's not like, oh,
you should be the last guy
to die in the mountain.
You claim to be this big mountain
here. And it's like, well,
you know what exposure, I don't
know. You know, living on it.
That's just my way of hiding the
fact that I was like really stupid.
It was a stupid thing to do and I want to,
I remember Dodi saying,
are you sure you want people to know that
this happened to you because it isn't
it kind of embarrassing to you. And I'm
like, yeah, it's embarrassing to me,
but I'm just going to talk
about it. Cookie bear me. So
she, yeah, my wife's like,
no way that we're just done
with the bear meat thing.
And my brother and my brother's
wedding were at his rehearsal dinner.
We're doing all wild game
for his rehearsal dinner.
So I had smoked up a ham off this bear
the longest serve it as rehearsal dinner.
He says,
don't tell anybody about the warm deal
because it'll turn them off to the whole
damn meal. And I said,
well, I gotta I feel now,
like I'll have to say this
has been cooked, but Fyi,
I got trick gnosis from eating this bear
uncooked and he thinks that he's just
like, I'd rather you not serve
it, then serve it and bring it up.
I think you should serve it in Indiana.
Decided not to serve it at his wedding.
I would have eaten it as long as it's
cooked to 150 degrees, especially smoked.
I know people aren't like that,
man. People aren't like that.
I smoked at ham from that
pig that we shot and a,
I cooked it to finish your in your,
your method with the brine.
Oh my God. It was some of the
best tasting meat I've ever had.
It was unbelievable. And that son of
a bitch, probably. Yes. I mean not,
not probably, but was a very good chance
he's got it. They you meet. Yeah. Yeah.
It was so tender and delicious, but
I've cooked a bunch of it. Just,
just put it on the grill,
just seasoned it and put it on the grill
and it's a amazing how tough it is.
Yeah. It can be tall. Shoot
through that shit, but tastes good.
Did you get a grinder? Yeah, I
got to grind, you know? Yeah.
I got a grinder for the venison
after Wisconsin Cowan and I,
we made buckets of hamburger meat. That's
good. Oh, it's so you can grind. Yeah.
That wild port to,
yeah.
I'd be curious just to take a piece of
that wild pork and send it in and see if,
if it has a,
it has trick analysis.
Do you want me to, I'll send it in. I
Dunno. I mean, what is that? I don't know.
What would you do with the
information if you knew? Uh,
make sure I did what I'm already doing,
I guess. Exactly. Yeah. I mean, I,
when I cooked it,
I cooked that the smoked ham I cooked
for like fucking 10 hours or something.
Yeah. It took forever. And you get it
out to the right temperature. Yeah.
Some people even,
yeah.
Say like Harold Mcgee's
science and Laura, the kitchen,
her science and Laura cooking,
whatever it is. It's a great,
it's like the science of food and food
cooking and ingredients is a phenomenal
reference book in there. He says,
it seems to be, I think the,
it was in his book,
he says,
it seems that there's evidence
to suggest that freezing.
Okay.
Kills it though. The USDA is
still sticks to that guideline of,
of cooking temperature,
but then like prolonged freezing kills it.
But a couple of years ago a couple of
guys got trick and from Walrus meet in
Alaska. Fucking Wallrose. Yeah.
So Howard ass on bitch got it.
But he's the Walrus at it and
they think that there might be,
this worm is tricky.
Nela spiral us I think is his name.
I got pictures of the thing on my phone,
what the world looks like. So, um,
that there's, nor they think there's
might be some northern varieties
okay.
In walrus, in polar bear that
are less susceptible to freezing
and that perhaps that freezing is not to
be relied on when killing these worms.
That it's a different northern variety
that's just got more tolerance. Hey man,
this is just something I read at fuck
is eating polar bear and Walrus. Wow.
People like Walrus. There's the guy,
you know, it's funny, I've never had it,
but I've been arranging to have
some because I drew um, uh,
Muskox tag for none of Eric Island
this winter. And when you hunt,
none of background,
if you draw that tag,
you have to hire what's
called a transporter because
the only place the land is
a Meeker rock on none of act
and it's a native village. Okay.
So into it or ask them, oh, village.
And these people like your
transporter can't do guide services.
Like he can't tell you where an animal is,
but he's like provides transportation.
So you rent snow machines
or Harvey getting around and
he'll give you a place to
stay when you're on the island.
It's called a transporter.
The transporter that I'm
using is a walrus hunter.
So they're protected by the Marine
Mammal Protection Act. Okay.
So like white guys don't go hunt Walrus,
but natives who aren't administered by
the Marine Mammal Protection Act have
their own self governing body
called the walrus commission.
And I think the wall was commission.
I came Emirates that meets and gnome or
Kotzebue and the walrus commission will
make decisions about what walrus harvest
different coastal villages are allowed
to have an out there on none of act.
Those hunters out there will periodically
go and hunt Walrus and the guy I'm
using as my transporter
goals on the walrus hunts.
So I've been encouraging him to make
sure to have some that I'd cause I'd like
to eat it when I come out and I'd like
to do a thing about that and hang out
with this guy and eat.
We'll always meet and he's going to,
he says he's going to make sure to have
some on hand and our Wa walruses like
when when you,
you were hunting walrus.
Like you're allowed to eat the meat
but you're not allowed to hunt it. So,
but if someone can give it to you, could
you bring it back? I don't know about,
you can't bring the ivory bag.
I don't know about transporting the meat.
That's a good question.
But yeah,
I could go into his home and I
don't even know the extent of it,
but I can go into his home
and he can serve me a meal.
Just like people might go up
to Nome or whatever and sample,
mock talk from a whale, you
know. Um, but no, I don't,
I know I'm fairly certain that
he could not give me the ivory,
you know, cause there's
like the, the ivory ban,
so I re has to have a cultural
marking on it. You know,
you're supposed to turn the artwork.
So a lot of times, you know,
like sea otters were nearly extra
paid in some places like regionally,
extra painted by the fur trade,
particularly when the Russians were,
had a strong presence in Alaska. And
now see otter numbers are, you know,
really recovered in a lot of areas,
but still for natives that are
allowed to trap sea otters,
they can't just sell the pelt as a pelt.
They have to do something to
it to make it a cultural item,
at which point they can
exchange it for money.
So if a native hunter kills a Walrus,
he can do scrimshaw on
that Tusk, you know, and,
and that puts that Tusk and a different
legal framework than it would as raw,
what they call raw ivory. Hmm. That's
fascinating. So I know, but yeah,
he can serve me a piece of wall.
Where's meat? But I don't know.
I don't know what laws govern me
walking away with some, I have no idea.
No seals. They eat seals as well.
They're allowed to hunt and eat seals.
The, uh, the natives and the Inuits
again, it's again, it's self govern.
I watched a Bordain show and he was with
this family and they were eating a seal
and they butchered the whole thing.
Yeah. That was in northern Canada. Right.
What's the,
what's there's like an autonomous,
it's sort of like on the autonomous zone
there. The name escapes me right now,
but yeah, I know what you're talking
about. And they're eating it raw. Yeah.
That doesn't have chicken houses.
I have no idea.
Or I don't know if people were surprised
to hear that Walrus has had trick
analysis. What does a walrus
eat? Well, they eat a lot of ELL,
clams, crabs. He lost. I
just don't know enough.
I don't know enough about how that thing,
God,
I don't know enough about whether what
kind of sea animals have that stuff.
I mean, was he in a chunk of polar
bear that you found frozen? None.
I have no idea. I would love to know
when I had Lyme disease, I did tons of,
I could've gotten an honorary phd in
Lyme disease after having Lyme disease,
and then when I got trick and Osis,
I started reading everything I
could find about triggering also,
but that just got better one day.
That's wild. So then I can read.
I quit reading about it just, you just
felt better. It's just a win away. Six,
seven days.
One of the guys that had,
he was running 103.9 degree fever for
six days and they're checking them for
like den, gay fever, West Nile virus.
He had no idea to even bring this up.
One of the dudes, girlfriends is
a doctor and she says, finally,
I think you boys got trick analysis.
I go into doc and I'm like,
here's what I think I got,
and they didn't know,
didn't know what the hell
I was talking about. Well,
you said 12 cases a year in the
entire country. They never see,
and there's four of you.
I'm asking me how to spell it once.
I was talking about a venereal disease
called Sherman Triggerman Nights,
but I eventually convinced a man,
just like when I had Lyme disease,
I walked around having to convince people
that I had that Lyme disease is really
common though I don't understand,
but it just depends on what that per,
what that particular,
I'll use the term what that particular
health care provider has run into,
and you go in and say like,
oh, I'm not feeling so hot.
You know, and this and that.
I think I got Lyme disease.
It's just like not,
I think if you're in Hudson Valley
in New York, you're going to walk in,
they're going to be like, hell
yeah, you got Lyme disease.
But in some places they're going to be
like, Eh, I don't know what you got.
Is it a weird,
when you talk to some dot,
I mean there's doctors are dismissive of
things like real dismissive and then it
turns out that you were right.
That's got to be infuriating. So
that's what I ran into and I,
and I've told the story a thousand times,
but when my boy, we got tricked, thank
God he didn't get trick and he got limes.
He's, he and I got Lyme disease at
the same time, fish and blue gills.
And He,
I was at my mom's in Michigan,
my mom comes up,
she was swimming with the boy and the
mom was on the same lake I grew up on and
she was swimming with the boy down
the lake and she comes up and says,
why is his belly button? I'll
read like this. I'm like,
I can't tell what happened there.
And it turned into one of those bowls.
I rashes my wife,
I send my wife a text image,
the text message picture of this thing
and my wife right away. It's like,
I wonder if he's got limes. He's,
it looks like one of those bulls,
bulls eye rashes.
They talk about Lyme disease.
So she tells me send it to
his pediatrician because
I had him at my mom's,
you know, she wasn't there. She's
like, send it to his pediatrician.
I sent this pediatrician and be like,
we're worried about what he's got line.
She's like, well, just keep an eye on it,
but you don't keep an eye on those things
to those things just go away like they
don't last forever. Right. So
all of a sudden then it's gone.
But clearly he had it and so then we wind
up going down there because then gets
another one somewhere else and
we'd go down and we're like,
we're really concerned he's got Lyme
because he gets this bullseye rash and
you're like, well where is it? I'm
like, well, it's not there now,
but it was there and he keeps talking
about this, that and the earthing,
different symptoms he's having.
We take them in three times
each time bringing up,
I fear that this is
what's going on with him.
When we pull them out of the bathtub
for whatever reason and the hot water,
he's got these damn circles all over
them, but they kind of go away. You know,
eventually he's got bell's Palsy,
he'd take a sip of milk,
is milk route at the corner of his mouth,
you know,
and we go in there like holy shit,
he's got Lyme disease now at this point
it's been going on for weeks. You know?
And what's funny is this place,
his pediatrician has a newsletter
and they had a newsletter article.
There was about Lyme hysteria about how
everyone is so hysterical about Lyme
being like don't really need
to worry about it. You know,
everybody's getting hysterical about Lyme.
Like it's the new bogey man, you know?
So in this altercation we have
with the pediatrician, I'm like,
I feel that your lime hysteria thinking
in your lime history article kind of
colored your impression of
what I'm telling you when I'm,
when we're coming in
and you're telling you,
and we had to self diagnose our child.
At which point they said,
I want to have someone else in the
room during this discussion. They,
they said that have it goes,
we were pissed.
Well you easily could have sued the shit
out of them if you were so inclined.
I listen and I don't want her, I'm
thinking of that stuff. But I mean I,
I was like, I entertained all kinds
of ideas if he didn't get better,
but he responded so quickly to medication
the, uh, but it, it was unbelievable.
And meanwhile I had all the same stuff
and I thought it was psychosomatic.
I wound up having to do the intravenous
stuff. You know, Doherty, he was real,
he was in the hospital lime meningitis.
Well when I ran into you when the
last time we went hunting together,
you were really skinny and I was like,
dude,
you look like you lost a lot of weight.
I lost a ton of weight during all that.
You told me the whole story.
I was even trying to drink like,
like milkshakes and stuff.
Like I was like not at GNC trying to
like do stuff and we or all those guys,
the guys in wilderness
athletes sending me like home.
I'm just trying to do anything I can
do to put on weight. Wow. There was a,
it knocked my dick in
the dirt bag, man. I bet.
I've heard nothing but horror stories
about people getting Lyme disease.
I'm nothing but horror stories. It's
just it. And then not only that,
your body doesn't really
ever get rid of it, right?
No, it's unclear. You
know? And if you like the,
the medical,
the established.
Okay.
Scholarly consensus online.
I think it's still this,
that there's no such thing as chronic
Lyme is what they'll say is what,
when I say they, I mean like the, the
medical establishment will say that.
Yeah.
That chronic Lyme doesn't exist,
that there's Lyme disease and when you go
through treatment, like what I did the,
the 28 day intravenous deal,
they put a line that goes in your arm
up to your heart and you inject these
syringes in it.
Like when you get done with that,
you do not have those
bacteria in your body anymore.
If you go to a Lyme specialist and you
tell live specials, I have chronic Lyme,
I met one, I tried to get in to see one
of these live specialist and she said,
category,
I don't see Lyme chronic Lyme patients.
I see a cute line patients
and I had already done one
round of antibiotics and I
got worse during the round
of oral and she's like, oh,
your chronic Lyme meaning like,
oh, it's all in your head. Why?
So I go to another
infectious disease person.
I was talking to them and they said,
well, it's like, it just seems kind of,
it's an urban chronic
lines and urban legend.
My finding wound up in some way,
bearing out what she said would
happen where I finished the stuff.
I think I got done with it sometime in
September and by November my symptoms are
gone. That's me. My boy
got better. But I've met,
I've since then met all of the people
who are very credible individuals,
you know,
who are not hysterical people who've
been through various rounds of treatment
and they're not getting better.
The are like the arthritic
stuff and limes. Such a weird
thing. Like with my kid,
you can't argue with bell's Palsy,
it's just right there.
But other stuff like folks who don't
know what that means, if it's paralysis,
facial paralysis.
Yeah.
I mean he had like bad facial paralysis
so you can't argue with it. Right.
It's just like glaring.
And that's one of the key.
That's one of the bulls eye rash,
Bell's palsy.
But there's all these other things
like a arthritic pain. Okay. Um,
fatigue.
They don't think a lot of people think
that all the time they were diagnosing.
Chronic fatigue syndrome was people
with limes, people, Lyme disease.
My friend's dad got it from the,
from getting vaccinated. They used to
have a vaccination against Lyme disease.
But the problem with it,
a small percentage of people that go
up vaccination would have some genetic
marker that would make them predisposed
to getting fucking Lyme disease from
this vaccine. He's guy was
terrified to getting Lyme disease,
gets a vaccination against Lyme disease,
got Lyme disease from the vaccination,
and then they stopped making
the Lyme disease vaccination.
So this poor guy has fucking Lyme
disease and he's still fucked up.
He's an old guy. It's her
dad and he's, you know,
he's jacked from this fucking vaccination.
I haven't checked this from multiple
sources. I just heard this or read this,
that, um, couple of interesting
facts about Lyme is one,
when my son and I both got it, I
remember being like, what are the odds?
Because you'd read that one or 2%
of ticks carry Lyme. So I'm like,
we would have had to have been covered
in hundreds of ticks for both of us to
have,
you know,
statistically for both of us that have
gone without even seeing any ticks. Like,
how could this be? Now later read
the, in that area in New York,
an area in Hudson valley,
they'd done some stuff for 60 or 70%
of the ticks have Lyme and they used to
chronicle 30,000 confirmed cases.
You know,
every year,
I think last summer they were
close to 300,000 this is blown up.
It is not so much that is
blowing up in new places.
It's just that is becoming like
much more common in other places.
Isn't there a direct correlation
between overpopulation of deer
and and these ticks?
Some people say that because it's
like in that things lifespan,
you know it gets on deer,
but I've heard all their things that even
just like rodents, you know, so like,
like smaller furred animals.
I'm not really clear on that man.
I don't really know. I know that
when you look at places that have it,
you look at places that
have a lot of deer,
but I don't know if if you
had a third as many deer,
if you'd have higher or lower or if you'd
have necessarily lower infection rates.
I can't answer that. But
Doug, Darren, who you know,
I think last summer
twice he got put on the,
the immediate antibiotics because now
when you find one of those ticks buried in
yet, if you go into a doctor and if
you're not weird about medication,
the doctors is going to give you
a super heavy dose of antibiotics.
It kills it before it gets a hold of you.
If you wait like I did,
it gets into your nervous system.
So I even had,
I even had for a day I had amnesia where
I'm sitting at my desk and I get up to
do something and I sit back down and
I didn't know who wrote what's on my
computer. Whoa. I started,
I knew I had to write about a subject
cause I knew that before the Amnesia
kicked,
I lost the whole day.
I lost like eight hours of time and I
knew that I was supposed to write about a
subject and here was a thing on
my computer about that subject.
I started taking sentences.
Okay.
And our first,
I took a big block,
like a paragraph of text and put it
into Google to try to find how I cut and
paste,
how I managed to cut and paste an article
on the subject I was supposed to be
writing about into a word document,
but there's no match.
Then I just started taking like little
blocks of words in quotes and there's no
match. I'm like, this is not from online.
Then I start thinking that one of the guys
I work with, I thought this Guy Jared,
Andrew Candace who was near
there who works at CPC,
I started thinking that he somehow
is playing some joke on you were.
He came and wrote about what I was
supposed to write about on my desk.
I also have a book,
one of my favorite books called hunt
high by Dunkin Gilchrist and on I had
written a Mark Boardman Vortex
optics. Okay. I look at the book.
I know the book.
I know who mark Bormann is,
but I can't imagine why Mark Boardman's
name would be on a sticky note on that
book and I look at my other hand.
On my hand,
I have l o p written an lop
is a term length of pull,
it's a firearm term and a guy wanted a
length of pull off a firearm and I row
lop on my hand. I looked at my hand
like I didn't know who put that there,
how long it had been there,
what it meant.
And I tried to go home and couldn't
get home. He couldn't figure it out.
I got on the wrong train, got off at the
wrong spot. We were living in Brooklyn,
got off at the wrong spot,
came up, recognized a sport,
recognize the like a sporting goods'
like a sports place called a camera.
It doesn't matter what it's calling
a sporting his place and um,
call my wife and told
her that's where I was.
And then all of a sudden things started
making more and more and more and more
sense. Wow. Dude, it was wild,
man. I thought I was dying.
I thought I was dying.
We did an episode of that.
Uh, Joe Rogan questions,
everything show on more jelly beans.
More Jones is this disease
that most doctors dismissed.
They think that the people
that are saying they have this,
that there's something wrong
with them psychologically,
that they have some sort
of a psychosomatic issue.
And that what they're really doing is
scratching themselves until they create
these abscesses.
And,
and then sometimes even putting things
in their skin and then claiming that
these things have been growing out of
their skin because they found like carpet
fibers and stuff in their skin that
these people sent in. Uh, but then, um,
when we went to these conferences where
these people would meet that have this
more challenge issue,
he realized you're also talking about
some seriously educated people and some of
them,
their doctors.
And one of the doctors that we talked
to said there's a direct correlation
between more gentleman's disease
in people who have Lyme disease.
I was all right. And what he said is very
intelligent guys. What does an a nutter?
And what he said is that he believes that
there was a neurotoxic effect that you
get from Lyme disease,
from some strains of Lyme disease.
Cause the way he said was, if you
look at Lyme disease, he goes,
you're not looking at like if,
if a tick infects you,
you're not looking at just Lyme disease.
But it's possible you might've
gotten 10 different. Oh yeah man,
I learned about a lot of that stuff.
Yeah.
And that one of those 10 different things
is causing this neurotoxic effect that
literally is making you go crazy.
So when these doctors are examining these
people and they said, oh they're crazy,
they think that carpet fibers are
growing out of their skin. No,
they have Lyme disease and the Lyme
disease along with all this other shit is
causing this neurotoxic effect.
And that is what's making them think that
there's something wrong with your skin.
So it's not that they're just crazy.
I said they have a disease
as making them go crazy.
And that was pretty illuminating because
this guy was talking about like seeing
things like seeing like worms underneath
his skin or eyes when he's looking in
the mirror. And he goes, and I knew it
wasn't there, but I'm seeing it anyway.
And he goes,
I could feel it moving across my eye.
But then there was nothing there.
And he's like,
and it was pretty clear to me as a doctor
that there was something going on with
my mind. Nope. That had a direct
correlation between this disease.
So all these people that
have this more jealous,
they also have this Lyme disease.
You know, I don't know if
Dan Dodi told her about this,
but he all of a sudden
has this excruciating neck
pain and he goes down to a
emergency room.
This is the same time this is going on.
When he goes down an emergency
room, it's like, oh, he got like,
they give him some muscle relaxers or
something and he comes back home when it
gets worse than weirder.
He goes down to another place
and they tell him the same thing.
He got pinched nerve and, and we're
text message and about, I was like, Hey,
what's going on? You know, high
feeling. And I remember that when I was
finally talking to a law,
a person knew about Lyme.
They kept telling me to move my neck
and see if it hurt and I told Dorothy,
I said, you know what?
When I was down there,
they kept asking me to move my head is my
neck feel weird, go down to that place.
So he just leaves his one doctor,
takes a cab down to this place where I
had gone and they admit him and he had
meningitis, was spent out in the
hall, you know, four or five,
six days in the hospital,
wound up with the picc line and meningitis
from Lyme and Zaydis whoa cause in in
your like an infection
in your spinal fluid.
I have a friend who died from that died
from meningitis. He went to the hospital,
went into the emergency room and he was a,
he was a comic and he was,
he's one of these, he was real busy
and you're just like fuck this place.
They're making me wait too long. I'm
leaving. And he got out of there,
got on a plane, flew to
Hawaii. When he got to Hawaii
he was dying. It's all right.
By the time he got there. It
was too late. I was, yeah,
I was scared cause I remember but there's,
I guess there's different forms.
There's been anyways,
his,
they did a spinal tap and you know he
was all messed up and meningitis is
subscale. Sean, I've had some of the
weird, in the last three or four years
I've had just some of the weirdest
like freaky health things,
but they're parasites. Mandy,
you've had giardia or something.
I got a colon infection from water and
that was from the other show, right?
That was from like wow. Within, no,
that was doing meat eater. So I had,
I like, I got really bad poison
oak was on steroids for that,
but also got some kind of waterborne
parasite and then the steroids combat your
ability to fight infection.
I want up in the hospital when
I'm like shit in my own couch.
My wife's like, I was like, listen, you
know there's nothing now. She's like,
I felt bad about like having you be there
when I was having babies. She's like,
you got, I got, you got dusted
off and you know your own coach.
So I couldn't even tell when
it was happening, you know?
Wow. I thought, oh man. Again, I
thought I was gonna die. So anyways,
I just had like just the weirdest stuff.
[inaudible]
he's like,
you need to go to a shaman because he
thinks that there's some thing like I need
to have like,
like there's some sin I committed
against the universe or something and he
thinks I need to go to
a sham and to get right.
Doty did too much t he did too much DMT.
Trust me,
you can do too much. You gotta you gotta
be careful with the fucking IOWASCA.
That's hilarious. That whole Sharman
things she says is a real trip.
You know,
the whole going to the jungle and
taking that medication and having these
spiritual experiences,
it'll get you convinced that everything's
all tied together and that somehow or
another you've committed some sort
of a sin against the university.
I gotta I gotta let you talk to, I can't
even, I don't want to speak for the boy.
I'm already talked about them too much.
I think Jody. Yeah, no, we'll Doty.
And I had a long,
extensive conversation about his IOWASCA
experience and I've never done Iowasca
but I've done DMT many times. I did it
again recently, did it last weekend.
And the,
the DMT
experiences essentially what Iowasca
is a orally active version of DMT.
Okay. Because the Amazon Shaman
and the people is derived,
it's from two different plants.
Okay. Well what are those little,
the first thing about this stuff,
DMT is dimethyltryptamine and it exists
in thousands of different plants.
And the reason why you don't get it,
like you don't get high when you eat
it is cause your stomach produces mano
aiming oxidate. So Mano
Aiming Oxidase, um,
what you need to do is take an inhibitor
so that you could get it in an orderly,
an orally active form.
So most of the time when most people
get DMT with they're getting is the
synthesized version where
they've taking, um, a coach,
you're a Veritas or all
these different plants.
They've extracted it down to the
DMT and then you smoke it. Um,
and what they do in the
Amazon, it's regulated in the
u s or not, it's illegal. Oh,
schedule one. The issue was scheduled
with it being a drug though,
is that exists in so many different forms.
You would have to make grass illegal.
I got like if you had flareups,
grass growing in your front lawn,
you essentially have a schedule run
drug growing on your lawn in massive
quantities. So it can't be
enforced. It's a weird but,
but if they find the powder,
if they find it synthesized and turned
into a powder that you could smoke and
freebase then it's illegal and
then it's a schedule one drug.
But it exists in your own
human neuro chemistry.
It's like making saliva illegal with
you. Literally that ridiculous. Um,
the Amazon Shaman have figured out a way
to take the vine of one plant and the
roots and the leaves of another
and they boil them together.
So essentially they use harming,
which is a natural Mao inhibitor and
they combine it with this plant and they
boil it into this potion
and that's what Iowasca is.
So it's DMT and an Mao inhibitor
together and this elixir,
you drink it and you have see what's
close to this smoked DMT experience as you
can get a but not quite as
potent, but it's not, it's not,
there's not a synthetic version
of IOWASCA. No, no, no. Well,
like it's all extracted from plants like
DMT has is not like they don't produce
it in land. Thank you can produce
it in a lab. I think you can,
but the precursors of it are very
tightly controlled by the DEA.
Like you can't,
like if they found out that you were
buying a certain amount of this chemical
that you would use to make the synthetic
version of it, they would flag you.
Gotcha. But the plants are
legal, so you could go online.
There was a guy that got arrested and
they took all of his money and locked him
up in jail because it was,
I think it was called happy frog
or something like that. One of the,
the name of his company,
I don't remember the name of his company,
but he sold all these legal plants,
but the plants were all totally legal,
but he sold them with the pretense that
you could take these plans and extract
DMT.
And then he was,
he was arrested for that because he was
putting a and B together for you. Yeah,
he, well, he was allowing you to
find the source to do it yourself.
But even though what he was selling
was legal, I think he got off,
I'm kind of speaking out of school here
because it was a few years back and I
didn't totally paid too much
attention to it, but it,
it is in so many different sources.
It is a hallucinogenic.
Yes it will.
It's a human neurotransmitter
and an incredibly potent drug.
That's also the most transient
drug ever exist or, uh,
one of the most transient trucks
ever observed. So if you get,
like if say if you'd smoked DMT
like I did, like I said last week,
your blasted to the center of the universe
for about 15 minutes and then you're
back to baseline.
Like you're completely sober in 15 minutes
if your body knows exactly what to do
with it. Yeah, your body knows exactly
what to do with it because it's,
it's such a normal part of
your chemistry that you're,
your body can bring it back to
baseline within minutes to weird.
It's the weirdest shit ever.
And the weirdest aspect of is,
while you're blown out,
like blown out in this
intense psychedelic state,
you immediately think, I'm here all
the time. I've been here before. Oh,
I know what this is. It does. It's
not unfamiliar. It's completely alien,
but yet familiar at the same time.
So Doty in all those Iowasca experiences
that he had when he was talking about
all these flashbacks
and all this craziness.
What happens is you open up this,
it's a weird effect where if you do DMT
and you have these powerful experiences,
you open up this door and I don't know
what the chemical effect of it is or what
the mechanism is,
but something happens when you open up
that door where you can open up that door
again,
even in a dream.
And so the speculation is that what,
what,
what happens when people have
like near death experiences,
when people have alien
abduction experiences,
when people have these crazy
things they say happened to them,
most likely what it is is some sort
of a weird and dodginess dump of DMT.
Like you know,
something can happen to you when
you get this crazy adrenaline rush.
They believe that it's possible that
something can happen to you and you get a
crazy DMT rush and that it's,
it's,
it's very difficult to access,
but that it's a function of
the brand is causing you to,
for lack of a better word,
is causing you to trip. Yes.
But you might perceive it as a memory.
You could perceive it at,
well it feels as real if not more real
than reality itself cause it's intensely
colored and brightly lit and the,
there's no borders to things.
But yet there are, it's very,
very, very difficult to describe.
I'm doing a terrible job
describing it and all around you.
It's alive with entities
and these entities are
communicating with you both with
sound and with visual cues. It's
a very, very, very weird trip. Uh,
you think in a negative way or if you try
to control it are like literally shake
their finger at,
you can go into an an an an an anonymous,
but then if you get it right, it calms
down. Like it's, it's like a lesson.
How to think. It's a very,
very bizarre, bizarre trip.
The most bizarre at of all
the psychedelics, by far,
the way I describe it is mushrooms
times a million plus aliens. Yeah,
it's the Mandalah.
It's the center of the,
of the Mandala of all this
is Mckenna described it,
the Mandalah of all the different
psychedelic experiences,
the center of it, the,
the literally the fucking 0.0.
The event horizon of that is
DMT. So do you feel like, uh,
to to,
to do it,
do you feel like you're being
recreational or constructive construct?
I try not to do anything recreationally.
I smoke a little weed recreationally,
have a drink recreationally.
But I think psychedelic experiences there,
so beneficial. I've gotten so much benefit
out of them that I don't, I don't like,
I feel like it'd be,
it'd be a waste to do you mean like
personally or as a performer? Personally.
Personally, yeah. Well, as a performer,
you know, eventually, personally,
first and as a performer I
benefit from the, you know,
whatever I get out of it
personally because, I mean,
it's all tied together with you,
but you know,
you don't think of funny
jokes or something. No, they,
the people don't tell you funny jokes that
you can put into your eggs. Nope. Nope,
nope. No. It's all about
correcting your, your bullshit.
It's almost like, all right,
you haven't been here awhile.
Come on.
And we've got to say it like go into the
dentist and you ever been to a dentist
in like two years.
You're one of those fucking guys sit
down and sit down and they find all kinds
of got going on here. Oh you got this? Why
are you thinking about this? That, that,
that, that the, the, the, the, the don't
think about that. That's just stupid.
You wasted your time thinking it's like
they sort of explained to you w w the
wasted paths that you're taking
with your thinking and your mind.
And then even with your actions.
So how long,
how long do the 15 minutes feel
like why did several in a day,
so I did a
three or four 15 minute ones in a row.
So a, you know, like just blast
off, come back to baseline,
hit it again. Would you be like, man,
that was just 15 minutes or would it
feel like you were gone like days now it
doesn't feel like days. It,
it, it's, it feels like it's,
when you're in the state itself,
it almost feels like time doesn't exist.
Like you're not seeing it unless
you think about it too much.
Like sometimes I'll think about like,
I don't want this to end so quick,
and then they like Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
Stop thinking all this stupid shit. Like
you're wasting your time. It's like,
imagine enjoying a great
movie and being like, man,
this movie's going to end soon.
Movies only 10 minutes in and I know it's
only got an hour and 50 minutes to go.
Shit, I wish it could go on
forever. That's a wasted thought.
Like why not just be in the moment
and enjoy it? So it's, you know,
that that expression be in the moment is
like so overdone and hippie and fucking
yoga. Like so many people say things like
that. And it just makes you moan like,
oh,
he shut the fuck up because it's like,
it's so cliched and
annoying when they say,
I know you're saying there's wisdom in it.
And unfortunately there's just so many
of these fucking fake spiritual people
that clog up all these words and they
ruined some of these definitions because
you know, oh, just be in the moment.
Find your center. Oh fuck you. Okay,
I'm not listening to your car.
Like I used to take yoga from this
guy who was a total bullshit artist.
He was a good yoga instructor,
but he was,
he was intoxicated by the fact that he
was teaching yoga and then all these
people came to him and his ego would feed
off of this is yoga class to the point
where he would say all these things and
you would see people roll their eyes.
Like my wife used to hate
him because he was so cheesy.
And then you'd like kind of hit on the
ladies that would be there and he want it
fucking some dude's wife.
And it was like a disaster.
Left his wife and she left her husband
and now they're miserable together.
It's was like he was like a fake spiritual
guy. And these fake spiritual people,
they have this way of ruining a
lot of like really wise notions.
One of them,
yes,
because they use, they're using it. Yes.
Tool. Well, you know, it's like,
or they're claiming to be enlightened
when really they're just a student on the
path and maybe they have some good
ideas along the way to enlightenment,
but they're not quite there.
You know, there's a lot of
that man. It's like a lot,
a lot of people searching like this
and these new age type people that are
searching for some sort of a meaning.
And if you find the wrong Sharman,
you find the wrong Yogi, find
the wrong guru. You could
go down a bad path. I mean,
the guy who was the head of Bikram Yoga
is got like all these rape allegations
of sexual assault allegations.
He drives a fucking Bentley everywhere.
He's loaded, he's got fucking gold
crusted Rolexes. And he's like,
clearly not a spiritual enlightened guy,
but he's the head of this
whole beek rum movement,
which is like filled with all
these pseudo spiritual people.
You know, I was sitting
there one day reading a book,
reading Al Sharpton's,
most recent books.
Finally she do the long
story and in Crayon, no,
my agent and my literary agent,
a representative Al Sharpton,
did a book with all sharp.
So I'm reading and Al Sharpton
Book and I'm sitting there in a,
in a guy's coming down the road walking
a dog and he looks like he's like a
yachtsman who guy walking a dog is like
clearly a yachtsman like yes, his world.
And he comes up and says to me,
you know,
you know I had a meeting with him one
time and he came up in a chauffeured car
and he had a Rolex watch on and he
proceeded to tell me how he lives on a
$23,000 a year salary.
It's like wow.
Hoses.
I don't know how old that story was.
I don't know how true to story was.
It was Kinda like he was sort of
like pointing out the, you know,
well there was a guy with a gun,
like a,
like a like an apparent discrepancy
or there's a massive discrepancy.
There was a guy once it was on this radio
show that I was listening to that was,
I'm the head of a corporation that was
approached by Jesse Jackson because there
were some,
something had gone on something where
they're racial insensitivity was,
you know, was there've been accused
of something that was racial,
racially insensitive.
So Jesse Jackson came on and essentially
the pitch was you are going to hire my
company to give seminars on racial
sensitivity and it's going to cost you a
quarter million dollars a year and if
you do not, we are going to protest.
You were going to make it miserable.
We were going to cost you far more than
it would then you would spend to have my
company come in the Rainbow Coalition or
whatever the fuck. Isn't that extortion?
It's illegal. It's not
illegal. It isn't. It isn't.
I mean it is illegal if
you call it extortion.
But what he's essentially saying is
it's within your best interest to align
yourself with grace out of court
settlement. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
And out of court settlement that they
profit from it in an incredible way.
But he had like all these crazy demands,
like he wanted to have
shrimp cocktail like a,
like Jesse Jackson had all these like
very specific demands as far as the kind
of food, the amount of food
that he was to be given, what,
what was supposed to go on.
You know,
what kind of car he's supposed
to be picked up in. And you know,
you look at Reverend Jesse Jackson though,
he's a religious man.
Well where's he getting all this
fucking money? He is a wealthy,
wealthy guy and he's wealthy by
being what they call a race pimp.
And that's how this guy was describing
it. He was like, he's a race pimp.
Like this guy finds these scenarios
where something goes wrong,
moves in and then extract
money from the situation.
I should send you my al Sharpton Boat.
I won't read it.
You won't read it because
it's a really good chapter.
Is One really good chapter in
that book where he talks about,
um, how people's positions on
things evolve over the years.
And I thought that was good.
Then there's a really horrible chapter
where he talks about how his role in
comforting Michael Jackson's family upon
Michael Jackson's death, or he, he's,
he's sort of presents himself
as the great hero. And
I think I read, you know, my age was
like, you're the last guy in the world.
I would expect to read a, um, uh, Sharpton
book, but I tell him, I said, well,
here's the thing.
That's probably why I'm reading it,
because all my life I've
heard about this guy. I,
I really don't understand who
he is or what he does. Well,
he's just one of these names,
you know,
it's like almost like
he's always got a name,
like Peta people hear it
and they roll their eyes.
Do you mean like, it's almost become like,
um, he'd cringe to hear someone say us,
but it's almost become like, like
he's almost the punchline. Yes.
He is a friend for so many
people. You know, if somebody
pundits and commentators,
you know, I realized that I was kind
of a victim of that or not victim mode.
I was like a doing that. Right. I
couldn't tell you what the guy did.
I couldn't tell you what he stood for.
But you thought of them as a punchline.
Yeah, I just knew that
of him, you know. Well,
you know the Tawana Brawley the, the
case that got him. Yeah, he wrote,
he talks about that.
Yeah. It was hilarious.
I mean he represented a woman who made
up a fake allegation of being raped by
white people and then wrote things on
her body and it turns out none of it
happened and she just made it all
up and he was demanding, you know,
justice and all this crazy
shit. And he was, you know,
on every television show and
all throughout, you know, the,
the news cases and all
this different shit.
And it turned out that what he was
doing was just, it was based on,
nothing was based on all lies.
It was based the entire scenario.
Jay jetted him into the public
eye. It was a fake scene. Yeah.
I can't tell you whether I read that
in this book or whether one of the many
people who saw me reading the book and
had to come and give me their 2 cents on
the subject told me,
well,
it's amazing that the guy became famous
for demanding justice for something that
never took place,
but it's a perfect analogy where it's a
perfect representation of who he is and
also how bizarre our sensitivities
are to race that will,
this fucking clown is on Msnbc or CNBC
or whatever the fuck he is giving his
opinions, all these different things and
his opinions are brutally dumb. Like his,
his way of commuting.
When he asked to communicate,
we asked to debate people who are
intelligent or nuanced opinions on these
subjects like his,
he's clear and obvious bias and his is
cookie cutter idea of racism in America.
Like racism is a real
issue without a doubt.
But having a guy like that represent the
black community almost fosters racism.
It's almost like if I was a racist and
I wanted to make sure that people had a
negative opinion of black people,
I would take the most clownish cartoon
versions of black leaders and feature
them prominently on television or
reinforce these ideas of these cartoonish
figures being this is what
represents the black community.
Isn't the black community silly?
You know, and that's what happens.
Instead of getting a Neil degrasse Tyson,
a Cornell west,
instead of getting these
super intelligent, very
articulate people with broad,
broad perspectives,
you get this goofball with a
fucking conked hair and you know,
a stapled stomach and he's a,
he's a goofball and he's many thousand
dollars suits on television demanding,
you know, reparations for slavery.
It's like, come on man, like this is,
it's almost a set up.
It's almost like the engineer racism.
Jesse Jackson barely can speak English.
I mean he's obviously an educated guy.
You obviously is articulate,
but his w if you're a
professional speaker,
which essentially he is,
his ability to enunciate words
is so sloppy and so confusing.
It's like,
do you know how you sound like you
almost sound like you're doing this on
purpose. You know, when does this, when
you would talk, cause this is like you,
you listen to him talk.
It's almost like he's too lazy to say
the words in a way that everyone can
understand though. There's like a, he
likes the cadence of it in some way.
Yeah. They used to do this. Neil degrasse
Tyson never speak out or does he ever,
have you ever heard him speak on race?
Talking about race?
I never have heard.
I'm sorry to hear him talk about what
he talks about professionally. Yeah.
He's talked about some other science based
things. Not just a astrophysics. I've,
I've heard him speak on genetically
modified foods and some misconceptions.
Some people. Yeah. Yeah,
I've heard him speak on some other things
that people have some misconceptions
of, you know, just sort
of science based stuff.
But I haven't heard him speak on race.
He's an interesting guy. He's a fun dude
thing on the incomprehensible
universe. That series. Yeah,
it's an amazing story. I think it's
like, I think it says what it's called.
Have you seen the cosmos? The, the,
the new version of it? It's great.
It's great because it also, he made it
very accessible, this version of the con,
like the story of Giordano Bruno,
I think that's his name,
the guy who was burned at the stake for
suggesting that the universe is infinite
and that they were like,
why are you fucking crazy bitch?
We're going to light you on fire
unless you tell it the less you repent,
that there a brick wall,
a brick wall out there as a ceiling
out there and behind that is a door and
God's out there, you know, and he, he was
convinced that it, that wasn't the case,
but he did the whole Giordano Bruno thing.
He did it in animated form.
It made an animation of it, which is
fantastic. It also made an animation form,
which you'll be interested in showing how
wolves became dogs and over the course
of human civilization evolving how these
wolves who had become friendly with
people had eventually gotten to the
point where the people were feeding them.
And the wolf stayed close and then those
wolves had slowly but surely morphed
into dogs. That's on
cosmos. Yes. Yeah. Amazing.
There's so much wild stuff coming
out of, um, did you say you,
do you know about those Russians that
were taken fox taken Fox and this? Yes.
And selective breeding. I don't know.
Just how fast you can change stuff. Yeah.
Yeah. Amazing. You can.
Yeah. When you all you,
all you need to do is look at what
they've done with dogs. You know, the,
the time that human beings have been mean.
What is the established timeline
for agricultural civilization is?
What is it?
10,000
yeah.
10 11,000 years anatomically modern here.
Like pick your number but 100,000.
Yeah. So in that time,
which is a blink of the eye,
you've made a fucking poodle out of a
wolf. Yeah, man. You've made a Chihuahua
one for one Americans for first pass.
And in North America they
weren't like breeds of dogs.
This is like the dog. They head.
That's crazy. You know, they weren't,
they didn't have like,
that's 40014001500 not at all.
50 probably some,
I mean it's hotly debated number,
but sometime between like some for
our oldest sites are 14,000 years,
but people think there has bee sites we
haven't found or we'll never find that
are older,
maybe 20,000 years.
But when like, like say when like
Daniel Boone came across America. Oh No,
they had breeds.
They had breeds.
Oh yeah.
When did they start having like when is
it a standalone? Do you have no idea?
It's so fascinating.
There's probably like, I'm sure
there's great stuff written about it,
but you know,
like they had,
so when the first Americans
migrated in North America,
they were traveling
with a domestic version,
you know, something that had been
domesticated for quite some time,
a domestic version of the Eurasian Wolf.
And then they came down and here
you had a number of wild canines,
you know,
wools,
which the animal they were traveling
with could breed with wolves.
You now find that in certain cases, wolves
and coyotes, they don't, they don't,
I don't think they always
put off viable young,
but they do think that there
are hybridization events
between wolves and coyotes.
So at some point these guys came
down with this Eurasia Wolf.
There was probably the, almost, certainly
there had been some in, you know,
some inbreeding with wolves
and an out of that stock.
Okay.
Created Lord knows what all you know,
because by the time Lewis and Clark like
you know when Lewis and Clark were out
and they were eating dogs,
the plains tribes,
they had those dogs weren't showing like
there hadn't been dogs that came from
Europe,
from colonists,
hadn't put dog blood into the dog blood
and they came and they had a dog that
looked like, yeah,
other, what they call it.
Like it looked like what they
now call him Vietnamese Amit dog.
Like just like a Mutt dog.
Multi like with multiple colors on them.
There was a recent,
yeah
thing where they've done a genetic study
on certain hybrids where they've found
a hybrid that's park, coyote, part wolf
and part domestic dog. Is there a, yeah,
is really recent.
Really rich
prize. Because one of the things
people look at is a, why are, you know,
coyotes in the east or just
different, the beggar, you know,
they feel that there's,
that there,
that there was hybridization
events of wolves and coyotes.
They gave you kind of like a,
like a bigger cow.
The East and you have smaller
coyotes in the west. Yeah. This is a,
from the Washington Post,
uh,
Coyote Wolf Hybrids are prowling
Rock Creek Park and DC suburbs.
What the fuck, man?
Real. This is it. Yeah.
This is a coyote wolf hybrid
in the Washington DC suburbs
and that nuts, Koi, Koi wolves.
And they've, uh, they've recently, um,
established that wolves
have returned to California,
the first known wolf, uh, you know,
within x amount of coming
out of where fall. Find out
is it like, uh, the red
wolves coming out of Arizona,
New Mexico?
I'll tell you right
now, because it's a, a,
a totally new thing that
they've proven it's from,
yeah. This, it's a, where
they've established it.
Um, the wolf's controversy,
we will return to California.
It's on Popular Science magazine.
Uh,
popular opinion is divided and how to
manage the gray wolf. So it's a gray wolf.
2011,
a male gray wolf called oh are seven
left his pack and Oregon and traverse w
1200 miles to California with a sore
travel is an atypical for gray wolves.
That terrain or seven covered
set him apart from the pack.
He became the first confirmed wolf in
California in almost a century. Maybe kid.
Yeah. And so had he been
collared and Oregon, he must've
been. It's good question.
It must've right if they've
figured out where he is.
You know, a guy in Missouri one time
killed one outside of his chicken coup,
we thought was a coyote. Nothing had come
from Michigan's upper peninsula. Well,
there was a guy who
crossed the Mississippi,
they killed a mountain lion in Connecticut
that turned out to be from South
Dakota.
You're about that fucking thing.
I'm telling you.
I was like,
I don't mean to say like I was on
this story long ago, but you know,
my entire life,
this debate about where La Mountain lions,
it turned up in the east or werewolves
that turn up and we were places my entire
life has been this battle between people
who'd be like, oh, it's escape pets,
it's escape pets.
You know?
And now it's becoming clear that in so
many of these cases it's not things just
leave now and then and they have a very
clear sense of purpose and they travel
tremendous distances.
Or seven, they actually got a trail
cam photo of this thing in California.
Yeah. And it used to, every time someone
saw something like that, people be like,
oh, you didn't see it or you saw an
escape pet and you'd think that like every
household had a mountain lion pat to
account for all the lines of guys.
It'd be like, it was a damn lion. Like I
found where something had killed a deer.
I went back. The next thing,
there's a lion sitting there,
biggest and escape pet.
This is pretty proficient, you know, it's,
my whole life has been
going on and now finally,
I mean the guys that have
been pushing for this,
I've ever finally got to feel a lot
better when now that through tracking
devices we're able to go like, yeah,
a wolf decided one day, you know,
to leave there and go down.
There was a grizzly that one day decided
to Mosey out of the Rockies and made it
out into eastern Montana.
You know, there's an elk that
did, uh, many. Usually it's,
you know,
usually these wide range and predators.
They got wolverines that I was
just reading a thing about.
They had a wolverine a little, because
this winds up being an interesting,
they did a rate, they're doing a radio
collar studying Alaska about a road there.
They think about putting a road
in into the Juno area. Okay.
So they've been doing a study on
animal movements in that area to try to
anticipate how this road might impact
wildlife and and to just to see about
their migration patterns
and moving her parents.
They went in and collared
a bunch of stuff.
They had a radio collared Moose fall
into a crevasse in a glacier and then a
radio collared bear tried to go in there
and get 'em out in Phelan and died.
And I think that was then scavenged
by a radio collared Wolverine.
They also had a wolverine.
They had a wolverine collard there,
get caught by a trap or
250 miles away and BC. Wow.
250 miles it would walked.
Wolverines are really rare.
Fine.
They're rare to find Tony.
That is one of the last things of large,
you know,
like North American fauna.
That's one of the last things I'm looking
for. You're looking for a wolverine.
I have not laid eyes on
one. My friends that, uh,
beyond a saw one Caribou
hunting, uh, my brother Dan,
he was hunting spring bears one time
and saw wolverines digging through the
debris field at the base of an avalanche
looking for critters that got swept up
in the avalanche.
Or I've got a handful of friends and
seen when I haven't seen one yet.
Those just badgers and wolverines and
those types of animals are so bizarre.
Dude, I was driving, I was
driving down the hall road,
the Trans Alaska pipeline road.
And you know,
you're up. Like if you go, if
you're on that road, like the pipe,
the road that parallels the
Alaska pipeline, Dalton highway,
if you're on that road and you go west,
you're not going to,
you,
depending on your line of travel,
you won't hit another road til
year in Europe and in Russia.
And then you go the other direction.
You're going to get way into
Canada for you hit her though.
I mean you're in the middle of nowhere
and not in the middle of nowhere,
but it's very remote relative to
anything we can comprehend down here.
Driving on that road one
time. Um, all out steps,
the links.
Okay.
And it looks like it's like a
cat with a baby's face on it,
like a human babies face on it,
man.
I'll steps the links and
like it's level to be,
to have an animal look at you like
that and it just, with utter lack,
lack of comprehension. Like,
I can't say this for sure,
but more than other animals. You feel
that he had never seen that before?
Never seen a person. It's just like
usually like you'll see an animal,
he cuts out in the road, right. And he
sees a car and he gets that like, oh shit,
no this ain't good.
You know,
based on whatever experiences he's had
or responses that he's witnessed from his
mother. Okay. Or like some sort of
like they kind of get tense there.
They're gauging risk but just this thing
steps in the road and just looks kind
of like, Eh, like this look on his
face and I'm anthropomorphizing here,
but look on his face was like,
no,
what in the hell is that followed by
utter lack of interest and just left.
He's like, he looked, I
don't know what that is.
I can't see this bringing
anything good to me.
And then wandered off and
it was one of the weird,
like that's the only one I've seen.
Look at that thing.
They don't even look real man. I'm
telling you what, they're freaky.
They are so tall.
Like how tall this thing is.
Like this high man, so like two feet
high just yet. Leggy though. Huge feat.
Just a weird, you know, they're
like snowshoe hare specialist man.
They like to hunt snowshoe hares so it
has big feet so they can get through snow.
Quite a hunter gatherer.
Snowshoe Hare special.
Well Cameron Hanes was telling me about
bears that come out of hibernation and
as they come out of hibernation is the
same time where the Moose are stuck in
the snow and that it's
just start flying snow.
And so the Moose are like plotting and
these bears come out and they haven't
eaten anything in months because
they'd just been hibernating.
But they see these moves and
they can't help but kill them.
So they just go on these rampages killing
every moose they find and just leaving
their carcasses because they
can't really handle meat yet.
Yeah, no, I got it. They, but they,
they like to have the opportunity,
had their instincts. He's just cause one
day come when they do come out, you know,
they'll come out and eat grass
for a while, he vegetation,
but they do spend a lot of
time, um, following that,
they spent a lot of time looking for,
you know, what we call winter kill, um,
just scavenging carcasses they can
find and then they hammer hammer fawns.
And that's something people use in that
realize about black bears is the high
rates of like fawn mortality get
from black bears on elk, moose,
deer, you know, they don't like,
it doesn't seem like they really go after
the adults like healthy adults under
normal circumstances,
but they really find out that blackberry
just turn up and hit calves and Fonz
and the way that no one ever thought
before they smelled that placenta.
It's like to have this idea of them
as being kind of like the kinder,
gentler bear, you know. But
there they'd know these spots,
they turn up in these spots before
things turn up there to drop Fonz,
you know,
the second mountain lion or third mountain
line I ever saw a saw cut and through
a bunch of elk calves and a calving area.
And you can just imagine how much the
thing like that can clean house. Yeah.
God Damn. When we were a bear hunting,
I got to watch Barrett's fight.
We watched a,
a fucking no holds barred brawl between
this female bear with her two cubs.
Oh really? Hale who had come into the
bait. They, she fucking went to war, man.
The bears, the babies climbed
up the trees. They were
way the fuck up the trees.
Like to the point where we were worried,
one of them got real squirrely.
He was like Kinda like
upside down on the tree.
Like he was way up there and
they're really young and uh,
the adults can't climb
because they get too heavy.
And this big male had come
in and it was a big female.
And first the baby's ran up the
tree and the female took off.
She left and then she was, she just
thought about it. She so you know what?
Fuck that.
And she turned around and attacked him,
turned around and challenged him and
they both went up on their back legs and
they were just going at it just
wow.
And we were sitting there on the
ground because Cameron is fucking nuts.
He likes to hunt on the ground. He
looks at Boalt Hall, no Tree Stan.
So we're just as like tree that's fallen
and we're set up behind this tree and
we're watching these
fucking, you know, six,
seven foot brown bears going
to war right in front of us.
I mean no more than 30 40 yards away.
Duke. Yeah. You gotta be wondering
like in the middle of this fight,
all sudden he comes rolling over
and here's your ass sitting there.
I was knocked up, man. I had
an arrow knocked and you know,
but like such a little kid, one of my
earliest memory is earliest memories,
but are being a little kid.
And my dad got a phone call one night,
one of his hunting buddies had, was
sitting on a bear bait, what is bow?
And a sal came in with cubs and smelled
them and shooed her cubs up a tree.
But they went up past him in the tree
and then they started squealing and
balling up there and she came up
mauled his legs that he loved. Yeah,
he went up in a hospital.
Fuck.
So she was a small enough that she could
make it up the tray. She got, well,
she's opened up to get at his
boots. But I mean, hey, you know,
I mean most of though, I don't know. I,
I've heard that that some blackbirds
get too big to climb. I don't know.
I mean they can climb pretty good. I
mean, and I don't know to what extent,
but I mean your typical barriers,
you typical blackberry can get
itself up a tree. She went up a tree,
the one that we saw,
she went up a tree a little bit,
but only like maybe five or six feet were
her kids went like they were 50 feet.
I'm sure it depends a lot on this,
your conference with the tree and whatnot,
but for sure we have a grizzlies don't,
I mean they when you're young,
but when they get older
they can't cut that tree.
Yeah, that's what they were saying they
were because they had tree stands there,
but he likes the Honda ground.
But he said, if you see a Grizzly,
then we go up the tree stand for sure.
Yeah, there's a bunch right there.
It was kind of like,
that looks cute,
but it was crazy to watch them Duke it
out like right there in front of us.
I mean it was white and went on for a
while and then he would come back and she
would chase him off again.
And then finally he gave up.
But then as it got darker,
she took off and then a bunch of
bears came in. When it's dark,
that's when it's really crazy.
Start calling. Alberta's
flooded with bears, man.
They said that there's between,
depending on who you ask,
between three and eight per acre,
and they're dealing with 8,000 acre
per square mile per square mile.
That's what I meant. And they're
dealing with 8,000 square miles.
So he said there's this bears everywhere.
And so the first time I got there,
you know, we, we sat down, we weighed him
like, where are all these fucking bears?
You know,
if there's so many bears,
like you think you would see one and
then when you see one and then you see
another and you don't hear him,
that's what's crazy because the ground
is thick with leaves and pine needles and
stuff. So literally all sudden
his parents are very, like,
he's there looking at
you, you know, from 70,
80 feet away, you know, just,
you didn't even see him coming.
Suddenly appears because it's so dense.
So many trees up there.
I was calling turkeys one time
and had a bear come behind me.
Um, you know like predators
when you're making,
when you're calling turkeys in the spring,
you're making head noises, track males,
um, check with toms, but
predators will come to that noise.
And uh,
I had a bear come in behind me that I
never heard until I heard it breathe.
It sounded like a dude and you're on the
ground sitting right in underground and
I here,
I mean this thing was right.
I mean right there like breathe
or my shoulder. How many feet
from oh five, six feet. I'm just there.
When I turned I was scared but that
thing was more scared when I turn,
he like turned himself inside
out. Man Just took off. It
was amazing. It was funny.
We were talking about like bears climbing
trees, black bears and grizzly bears.
Um, I wrote about this at
some point, but we are,
my brother and I were laying on this
ridge one time hunting elk and like during
the mid day when it's warm,
like nothing happens, you know,
we'll just go sleep somewhere and wait
for the elk come back out cause they go
into black timber just to feed bed down.
So there's really no sense and there's
nothing you can do. You just sleep.
And at one point I wake up cause I hear
a noise and I wake up and was a black
bear standing there and he goes off down
this ridge line and I'm sorry it just
goes down off the ridge down
toward the valley floor.
That night we headed out to go hunt.
Uh,
we headed out to go hunt elk and we
happened to go in the direction that the
bird went and my brother's
still had a bear tag.
I had filled my bear but he still
had a bear tag. And as we're walking,
I hear the noise of its claws
on the bark like real loud,
you know like barks,
phone and scratch,
you know you manage like what a
cat would sound like or something.
Scratching up something.
I'm like that must be that black bear.
So we go hauling ass up to tree thinking
that will maybe get the bear up the
tree and bill check it out but run it.
There is not a black bear.
It's a sow grizzly standing there and
she's got two cubs that are about four or
five feet up this tree and she's standing
there at the base of the tree and she
woofs that.
It was like a dog like oof barking,
you know and those cubs come down the
tree and we're just standing right there
man.
It was like you can't,
you can never say it was close to getting
scratched unless you got scratched
cause you don't know what's
in the animal's head.
But like reviewing it in my head,
that was one that was like
a very sketchy moment,
you know as that bear kind of like,
cause it's like the last thing
you're supposed to do. Right.
It's like mess with their cubs and here
we are just running up on there and when
she got those cubs down the tree and they
started going up the hill away from us,
she was taking her paw and
moving the cubs with her.
Paul. Wow. Pushing them ahead of her. Wow.
It's the same way like you know when
you'd like trying to get your kids to go,
we want you, I saw your hand up guys.
I got your hand on their head or yeah.
It's about trying to guide him. You know
why she's like giggling and giggling.
Wow. That was wild man. But she could
have spun around to scratch those things.
That's the big reason why a lot of
people are hikers get attacked. Right?
It's a female with their costs coming
across something. Yeah.
Like this blew my mind.
I just read that not a single bow hunter
has been killed by a grizzly bear.
You know, while bow hunting, even though
boners get scratched up all the time,
like every year there's some
guy getting scratched up now,
the single bow hunters, men killed by a
grizzly bear and at least 20 years. Wow.
You know, last year there was like three
grizzly bear fatalities in Montana,
Wyoming.
Well,
that was one of the things you saw on
that hunt show was how difficult it is to
bow hunt for grizzlies because they,
first of all,
the Kodiak island was very windy.
Like these guys were like,
they were taking shots in the air would
just take off and missed the [inaudible].
This is miserable and wet. You
got to get so close with, oh man.
It's one thing like being a stand
and waiting for a white tail to walk
underneath you,
but to creep up on a fucking giant
nine foot bear that's outside.
You got to get within 30
40 yards of this thing.
Don't get an accurate shot on it
and it's windy and everything there.
But now in that show,
they're doing that. This happens
a lot, but I know that like
shows don't show it.
And outdoor writers don't write
about it, but oftentimes, very often,
I can't say it's the majority of time.
I was like a very common practice when
a guy's bow hunting brown bears is the
minute
that Arrow makes contact with that bear.
The guides lightened it up
with like a three 75 h and h.
So there's shooting with a gun right
after the minute that arrowhead. Yeah,
that's probably smart. I mean,
I saw that on a show. It was a,
a bow hunting show with this guy shot
a fucking elephant with a bow and the
elephant turn and you're like, fuck you.
And elephants starts running it and boom,
they shot him in the head with a rifle
and like he's going to call that I hunted
an elephant with a bow.
Like the fuck you did.
All you did was pissing elephant off
and it charged you and these guides shot
the elephant in the head.
They killed the elephant.
Yeah, I'm not, I'm not diminishing
the balls it takes to get in there.
Like I watch the thing like, you know,
I watched thing where uh, Tom Miranda,
you know, kills like a big grizzly was Bo
and by no, I mean by any means. Like he,
it was like he got a great hit on
that bear that bear ran and fell over.
I'm not saying that's what I was saying.
You hear about it so off,
when you talk to guide so
often and even do with rifles,
even we've got hits it with a rifle.
He's going to start pumping. Led. Yeah.
It's just so hard to anchor them in and
then they go on those orders and you
don't want to lose them.
So don't want to go in there after him.
Take the initial shot,
they consider you shot that bear and
then everybody else in the guy, you know,
or whoever can can do a follower really
didn't like watching them shoot the
elephant. There's something to me about
shooting some animals where it's like,
I don't get it.
Like why would,
I don't know why you would travel all
the way to Africa to shoot an elephant
with a bow while these people behind you.
Rifle it and you're calling that bow
hunting. I wouldn't shoot it. I don't,
I couldn't shoot an elephant
just because I like, I don't
have, I didn't, I don't have
like a, a context with the
animal, a cultural context,
you know what I'm saying?
Like with North American animals,
I find that generally when I go hunting
and I'd like to have had an experience
with it and understand sort
of you don't understand it.
And it would be for African hunting
for me to like enjoy it on Africa.
I would probably want to go there just
to have a look around and be there and
then maybe go again just for
me personally, then go again.
And I might enjoy hunting more.
Once I sort of felt like I
understood the animals, you know,
or I understood more about the
biology and the sort of like,
I just understood the area
better. It would make me feel
more like, like, uh, like,
uh,
like to what I want to have in a,
in a Predator prey relationship.
We're going down to film this year.
Uh,
we're going down to Bolivia and we'll
go out hunting with Amerindians or go
along on a hunt with Amerindians
and, um, you know, they,
they go out and do meet hunts for Cathy.
Borrow Pako they both fish for fish a lot.
One of the things they like to hunt is he
liked to hunt spider monkeys, you know,
and I've always valid, I'll
never eat a monkey. You know, I,
I always say that I'll never read monkey,
but now I'm going to be down
there and he's guys, you know,
presumably they're going to get a monkey
and they're going to cook it and you
gotta try it. I can't decide, man.
Yeah, I'm not in the eating primates.
I just feel like,
you know,
I can't decide what I'll
do when I'm sitting there
dogs and didn't like it at all. Well,
you ate a coyote, which is crazy.
Then they'd be like, that didn't
bother me. And like an emotional way.
But I'm saying I tripped out
emotionally about eating a dog,
so I can't imagine what I might suffer
to be chewing up a prime primate.
It's just like, I remember reading
one time and this kind of, I was this,
explain this to my brother the other day
when I was talking about this conundrum
I'm in,
where I was reading about a guy who was
the screen he was describing the hunt
from monkeys and a dude hit a,
and he was observing,
he was observing south,
you know,
South American tribal
hunters or Amerindians.
He's observing them hunting monkeys.
And the monkey got shot in the back
and a monkey with a dart and the monkey
reached around and
grabbed the dark. Whoa. So
they image it was just so burned my head.
But I think like, I don't know
what I'll do, man. I'll be curious.
I'd be curious if the guys I work with,
if they want to eat the monkey or not.
Yeah. But there's so many weird
things. He'd go like this.
So these guys are indigenous hunters.
They hunt, they make their own bowls,
they live in the jungle.
Like any kind of thing,
like if you went out and
surveyed a hundred Americans,
a hundred would say like,
by all means, if anyone can justify
hunting to be these boys, all right.
Um, they're going to be their hunting,
whether you're with them or not.
So it was kind of like, you look at,
well, monkeys dead now. Yeah. I guess
I could see that.
What I couldn't see as going there
with a purpose to go shoot a monkey,
I guess if I was there experiencing
what it is like for them.
And also if they offered me a mom,
like it was part of like you're,
you're taking into their home and they're
cooking you a meal and they ask you,
you know, they serve you what
they eat, maybe then I would,
no, there's no way I shoot. There's no way
I'd shoot a monkey. Yeah. By saying that,
I don't think that one shouldn't
be allowed and whatever, you know,
it just depends on the, the consensus
of biologists and whatever area,
whether it can warn and or not. But no, I
wouldn't, it just like I couldn't, yeah,
I couldn't either. But I know that they
have issues with baboons and people.
Dude in Africa, I, it's just
like, I guess I can't get it.
But in Africa you get the
sense that people view
like baboons, almost like how you
might like a, I hate to say it,
almost like you'd might
look at like raccoons and
opossums that are getting into
your dumpster. Yes. But
they, they'll kill a baby. Oh,
kill a human that are stolen human.
The first thing about Cameron Hanes,
who just got back from Africa,
he shot a fucking baboo, went over there,
shut up abdomen with a bow and arrow.
And I'm like, why don't you shoot a
baboons? And he's like, they actually
courage you to shoot them
the baboons as possible.
Cause they're overpopulated
and they're really dangerous.
That's a friends of mine
told me, man, do, uh,
do the guys in Africa eat the baboons?
No, they don't need it. Baboons.
And they don't need to hygienists
and they don't like the high end.
No,
they killed him.
They killed him whenever they can
because they're so overpopulated,
but they don't eat them.
But he ate a kudu.
He shot a kudu over there and eat
that and he said it was amazing.
Yeah, said Kudu. Kudos. Like similar
I guess in a lot of ways to deer,
elk and a, the way it tastes. The word
overpopulated, just such a weird word.
It's such an abused works.
Whenever I hear that always get be like
according to whose perspective because
again and again and we're telling
like deer overpopulated like, yeah,
I mean from the perspective of
some agricultural interests,
dear overpopulated from the
perspective of auto insurers, you know,
deer over populated from the perspective
of Lyme disease activists, you know,
deer over pilot, but from a perspective
of dude who likes to eat a lot of deer,
you might be like, now's the good old
days, man. It's like this is perfect.
If I lived in some areas,
Mary's a western Massachusetts
that are so flooded with Deere,
I would definitely have one of those
crazy bumpers on my truck. You know,
they have those crazy big steel.
Well they make them specifically for
deer to withstand a deer hit. Yeah.
There was one of them that they were
pulling up photos over the other day of 18
wheelers that they have these giant ones
they put over the front of their trucks
because deer,
you know,
are so common and in a lot of these areas
where they're transporting stuff and
they had one where this deer,
it just, it had hit it and the,
the guard did its job but the fucking
entire truck was just painted with blood,
you know, cause it was all 65 miles
an hour and you hit an animal.
It's basically a bag of them.
It vaporize,
vaporize them such a disturbing way.
I recently wrote a
thing about this on the,
on the mediator show website where I was
about these recent controversies where
someone will go and kill a African animal.
You know,
I can like a lot of those
pictures by the way,
tell people where they can
get that because I loved
your perspective on it and I
loved one of the things
you pointed out about,
you've seen all these things where
people are getting pissed off.
These pretty girls that are going over
there and shooting these animals and a
lot of it is sexism. Oh yeah man. It
pit for a girl to go to African hunt,
pisses off people way more than for a
dude to and also for a wealthy person hunt
in Africa pisses off way more people
than the middle class person hunting in
Africa, which is just
weird. Like you know it,
it's so beyond the
biology is just like weird
sexual stuff. It's weird. Nv class envy,
however you want to think of like
whatever you want to determine about the
legitimacy of hunting.
And Africa's really have nothing to do
with the gender of the hunter. Yeah.
But this, this one point I tried to make
an it thing that I wrote. You could,
you could find if you just go on, you
could probably even type in like, uh,
Steven Rinella African hunting
controversy or go to the,
to the meat eater.com you'll
find the article. But,
but a point I make is when people look
at someone posing with an African animal,
like a lion, they, they,
I think people look at and they
feel like they see a dead movie star
because they don't know like all you
know of that animal is sort of wildlife
documentaries and then cartoon
versions and the Lion King. It's like,
you feel like you're looking at that.
But in America we drive down the road
and we see just like contorted pulverized
deer carcasses. Yeah. You
can't escape it. Yes. Yeah.
And so I feel like it's never
going to be as offensive. You know,
w when someone sees a dead deer,
it's not as shocking to them is be like,
it's the animal from the movies
and then killed it. You know,
anthropomorphizing of an animal.
It's a real issue when it comes
really feels the people more like,
I remember a friend of mine who
worked in the environmental movement,
or I shouldn't say that, cause I,
she was a conservationist. Okay.
As you were in the conservation
movement and she complained about, um,
half jokingly about charismatic megafauna
so that so much mental energy of
Americans gets tied up in the preservation
of charismatic megafauna and those
things become such
money sinks that we miss
opportunities to understand like this
vast suite of other creatures out there
that doesn't make it onto calendars.
And she was, if I remember,
I think she was speaking
of the amount of research,
dollar dollars and public interests
and things that go into wolves like
understanding wolves,
you know,
and there's all the other animals that
she calls like non charismatic megaphone,
you just can't get someone
to like care about them,
you know? And I think that's, that's
one as far as conservation goes,
I think that's one thing
that that conservation
organizations that are based off
of specific animals wise tie is that
they're looking at like apex or keystone
cornerstone species.
So like a group like the National Wild
Turkey Federation and the Rocky Mountain
Elk Foundation, they will point out,
they'll be like, yeah, this is about elk.
We have elk on our symbol.
You might think that we fetishize
l but I can tell you this,
what's good for elk is good
for everybody. Yeah. You know,
it's one of the most demanding,
like least tolerant things.
And so if you preserve
elk wintering habitat,
you're also at the same time preserving
the habitats and so many other species.
And you might not say the same thing
about if you went and preserve the habitat
of, you know, some animal,
the more restricted
home range or something,
it might not blossom outward to offer
protection for all these other things.
So that's one way in which
like the charismatic megafauna
thing winds up playing
out is people go like, yeah, but by
helping him, I'm helping everybody.
So I'd like to have
something for my calendar.
People have that aversion
to a trophy hunting.
That's one of the other things that
drives people nuts about Africa.
Is it people going over
there for blood loss,
they're going over there just to kill.
They want to stuff it
and put on their wall,
this beautiful animal that should just
be observed and appreciate it for what it
is. Yeah. I,
that's something that I struggle with
an earlier I made a turn about something
being like a, like,
like a semantics thing.
Because if you go in hunt and you keep
something like you have right here in
your studio, you have a uh, a deer antler,
you gotta like a deer skull, right?
By really any definition
you'd say like you'd be like,
well that's a hunting trophy,
you know?
Does that make you then a hunting
trip like a trophy hunter,
even though you ate the deer
to be a non trophy hunter,
would that mean that you should have
thrown that deer head in the garbage in
order to be more peer?
Or is it more peer that you'd have
that you'd maintain that emblem and pay
respect to the animal in
perpetuity by having its head here.
So it's like you kept a trophy,
you kept the meat and kept the trophy.
But when people hear trophy hunter,
I think what the,
what that means in our culture is that
someone that just hunts for that purpose,
like he just wants to go kill that thing.
And this comes from guys
never hunted in Africa,
but so much of the controversy about
Africa is that people are going there and
killing animals just for the
head and bringing them home.
And that way you're probably
trivialized and you experience,
but you're also not really looking at the
broad picture of how game gets managed
there and the importance
that the commodification of
wildlife plays in Africa.
Where here we have public owned,
publicly owned wildlife, you know,
so and we have a really strident system
where stringent system where we can
protect legally protect stuff.
But in Africa there's a great
argument to be made for.
If it wasn't for the value of
those animals to Westerners,
if it wasn't for the hunting industry,
those animals wouldn't be in
those places where they are. Yeah,
they have those animals that way too many
forces and factors that would lead to
those being like ravaged ecosystems
from hunting from people,
I mean hunting farm,
people who are starving or who are
wanting to graze livestock in those areas.
And the fact that you bring in a currency
and you monetize them enables people
to preserve these large tracks of
land and have animals on there.
So you can look at like,
what is Joe Blow's motivation?
Joe Blow's motivation might be,
he thinks it'd be sweet to have a zebra
hide on his floor and you can condemn
Joe blow for thinking that.
But you really, to be fair,
you have to look at the impact that,
that money that he spent to get it
has on the broader economy and on the
wildlife politics of that place.
So it's way more complicated than what
anyone individual's motivations were.
You know? And it's just, I
just caution people and I,
and I,
I'll tell you what,
I've had my share of looking at pictures
of guys hunting an African and being
like,
dude,
you just went out and paid someone and
he showed you that and you're like, well,
that's what one of those is in shot it.
I've felt that a thousand times
looking at those pictures.
But it's one of those things that the
more I've learned about it and spoke to
people who've gone there and,
and read about it,
the more I've come to
admit that you know what,
what's going on in Africa is vastly more
complicated than what you're going to
get from reading about
Internet controversies that
people posting pictures.
You really need to study up on that stuff
before you condemn it because I think
you'll be, you'll be kind of
shocked by some of the stuff
if anybody's interested in it further.
We're just about out of time.
But Louie thorough has a documentary
through, how do you say his stand through,
through Louis through has a documentary
about a African hunting camps were kind
of goes into great detail with these
guys that run these camps about how these
animals, they essentially
wouldn't be there if it wasn't,
they would be extinct and we were on, we
were at a time. Okay. Um, all right dude,
uh, your book, you've got the
buffalo books published. Oh No.
You know what my first book,
MMM.
Which never had a chance in the real
world scavengers guide to oat cuisine at
came out long time ago. But I
got the rights to it back. Right.
And I published it digitally
as a scavengers guide.
MMM.
I hope people go read it.
It never got red on it came out like not
like my other books did man. And I've,
and like I said, they just
gave me my rights, writes
back, how's it going to get
it? How can someone get it? Oh,
it's on every place you can
buy digital books. Okay.
We'll put it goes on everywhere. We'll
put a link up to it, uh, after the show.
And I also put a link up to the Daniel
Boone thing that you did the animated
thing. Great. Joe was just up
to the time flu. It's over.
Hey, thank you for having me now.
Anytime, man. Anytime we she lived closer.
We do it all the time.
Well,
you are kind of closer now and we're
going to be real close when we're sharing
the same tent pretty close. All
right, folks, thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to blue apron.
Go to blue.com/rogan
and, uh, get two meals for free.
Thanks. Also to meet undies,
go to me undies.com forward slash Rogen
get 20% off your first order and go to
rogan.ting.com and get 25
bucks off of any ting device.
All right, if fox, we'll be back soon.
Uh, tomorrow. In fact, see you soon. Bye.
Okay.